now that donald trump is
no longer you know in office and the
media is
eternally desperate for something to
talk about
they are starting to for one talk about
trumpism
say trumpism is fascism and a whole
bunch of other just
who cares you know look man trump had
his time and he might come back he may
be a big player in the midterms and
moving forward but for the time being
right now
joe biden is the president stop talking
about donald trump they can't though
they're obsessed
well something is taking the place of
donald trump in a different way and it's
alexandria ocasio-cortez why
she's very much like trump now obviously
not politically of course
not age-wise and trump's an old white
guy and she's a young
woman of color but when it comes to
social media presence and the things
they do there are a lot of similarities
the other day we talked about how the
media was overly distracting us because
of this ridiculous
nonsense related to ocasio-cortez and
the critics we actually
have now a substantially more relevant
story
when aoc told her story about being in
the
capital riots and and fearing for her
life and the cop banging on the door
i said look i can respect it right if
you're scared and you've never
experienced this
i'm not going to complain about that i
get it i don't expect everyone to have
experience in riots well it turns out
her story isn't true
so uh there you go now trending at
number one on twitter is alexandria
ocasio-smollette
no joke they are comparing her to jessie
smallett trending
number one in the u.s on twitter maybe
more i don't know but this is now a
substantial political story
because it sounds like aoc was actually
lying there's another video people
pulled up where she contradicts her own
story
it's one thing to give a heartfelt
emotional story about you being scared
and have people criticize you and that's
needless drama
it's another thing when a very high
profile a politician
lies about what really happened in order
to garner
power and and political support and that
makes it a much more substantive story
albeit
normally i don't care for the drama but
there is a line
and i would i would say it's when we
catch politicians and outright lies
and so i still kind of roll my eyes at
talking about aoc but
that's that's just the story but we do
have a bunch of other stories uh the
good news for for lukowski who's here
with us is that he's now a person of
color
this is this is not there's no joke i'm
not kidding it's so what is the
coalition of communities of color is
that what i believe so yes they said
that slavic people based on their
determination and
the oppression now are people of color
we're turning not just
we're not going to just do a segment
about this i
now proclaim that we're going to be
talking about the
this just in the entire show so uh this
is now the lucas
irl show thanks so much for giving me
over uh your show tim
well this is a good point see for a long
time i said this is a minority owned
company because you know i'm part asian
but as you now know asians are no longer
part of the people of color because it's
by pockets
you know uh black indigenous people of
color they removed asian from it so
i'm out oh yeah i'm you're whiter than
white i'm whiter than white
so excuse me don't interrupt me i'm uh
i'm speaking please
stand aside give up positions of power
for people of color exactly
thank you thank you jack this changes
everything for me
uh if you want to support a minority uh
people of color business you can i'm on
we are changing
forward slash donations as soon as i
heard this i had to check my credit
score you got to go on google and list
your business i am i am
i'm going to i'm like we just found
about i found out about this right
before the show so i'm going to go after
youtube for discriminating against me
and demonetizing my youtube channel
all the censorship efforts it's odd yes
it's on like donkey kong
and now i mean this changes everything i
love it so much
so you guys are you guys are allowed to
speak go ahead okay okay well we have a
uh we have we have a bunch of other news
as well
you know chris pratt they're trying to
cancel chris pratt because someone made
a bunch of fake
tweets and i i do think it's interesting
of course they're always trying to
cancel somebody
but they're legit trying to get a dude
like pulled from his movies or whatever
because someone made fake tweets of him
and we're entering the deep fake era so
there's a lot we can talk about there
for sure we got
covet is apparently disappearing great
down 44
just gone no one knows why no for real
they're saying it's not vaccines
we don't know what it is it's just all
of a sudden it's going away and uh maybe
maybe trump was right remember when
trump said one day it's gonna go away
after the election and it did what he
did yep yeah that's
that's really interesting so uh you know
we'll get into these things and
of course i mentioned lukakowski's here
i am tweeting up a storm i'm going to be
tweeting a lot more
also on instagram under luke we are
changed so uh look out for some uh crazy
memes i just memed a really funny
alexandrio ocasio-cortez
very good definitely worth checking out
and yeah i also release videos i'm an
independent media creator on the youtube
channel we are change thanks for having
me we're hanging out with jack murphy as
we normally do on wednesdays
what's up everybody glad to be here jack
murphy at jack murphy live on twitter
and uh jack murphy live on youtube check
it out new videos coming
almost every single day now come down
subscribe please
of course murphy in the house
that's right every other wednesday i
love it
uh so we completely jumped the shark
here kovid's on its way out and luke's
luke's the colorful that's not jumping
the shark how dare you
mock my designation ian don't make me
expel you from society can i fall asleep
for a hundred years what's
i don't know i don't know what's
happening right now i mean this is great
so i gotta i really want to go into this
covet story this is this is the biggest
in the universe right now if that's if
that's really there's also a very
important announcement by the world
health organization but we got a lot to
get into so let's just get right into it
and i think we also have one more person
right we do we have me in the corner
pushing buttons i'm the sour patch lids
producer she is pushing all the buttons
and before we get started make sure you
go to timcast.com
become a member my friends because uh
censorship is a reality i mean
no joke in the event that we do get
purged we'll have our presence here at
timcast.com but in the meantime we have
bonus episodes we legit have a full
bonus hour where me you know it was it
was ian sheamus and myself talking about
life after death religion spirituality
it's a very interesting conversation you
can check that at timcast.com for
members only so
sign up help support the channel don't
forget to like subscribe hit the
notification
bell and share it with your friends all
that good stuff i bring you now
to twitter number one zio smilette
and number three is kyle right now we'll
get into that later it's a crazy day i
guess all
filled with all sorts of all sorts of
drama but here's here's the the actual
big news from red state
aoc wasn't even in the capitol building
during her near-death experience
this isn't just one story all right i
mentioned this the other day we ragged
on the idea of the drama
because the drama was aoc was like yo
the capital thing happened and i was
scared and i went
okay i get it and then michael tracy was
like that's manipulation
and then the media picked this up and
made the story about michael tracy
tweeting at aoc and then the young turks
is like oh smackdown and i'm like dude i
don't care
i don't care the news about aoc telling
a story and then some journalists
criticizing her so what
well the story today is actually
substantially different aoc now has
three big lies one that she feared for
her life this is the first thing she
said i was scared i was gonna die that
day
the next ted cruz you almost had me
killed in the third i was terrified
because the rioters were coming and you
know there
the cop was was banging on my door and i
don't know what's going on i was hiding
she wasn't even there now she responded
to this claim saying that's a smear
taking advantage of people who don't
understand the capital complex
so jack pasobic posted an image showing
that the building she was in was across
the street it's not same building but
there's tunnels tim
there's tunnels you don't know about the
time i know about the tunnels no that
was her response but they didn't go in
the tunnels they're also
connected through electricity okay and
this thing called wi-fi and internet i
mean they're all interconnected so i
mean
they could have came through the phones
jumped out who knows now look
i try r i i refrain for the most part
from criticizing parts of her story the
other day because i want to get in the
drama
one of the aspects of her story was that
while she was hiding from the mob
apparently
she had her staffers in the lobby like
what like to confront the mob for her
it's insane they should all have been
hiding white people to the front
i don't think the person was white but
but no more importantly
it just wasn't a true story yeah it was
at at best in her case a total
embellishment
that uh okay i get it people they did
they did evacuate the building where her
office
is and that was because there were
concerns about maybe a bomb threat or
something but nothing to do with the
writers
and so she's telling the story of her
like pinned up against the wall scared
the rioters were coming
tons of news outlets actually wrote that
the riders were storming the building
they didn't even fact check any of this
she wasn't even in the building
imagine the goal to understand that the
country is so much in trouble
so divided and what do you do in that
moment
look at me i almost died and he almost
killed me i mean that's absolutely
insane there's a meme going around with
her that famous photo of her at the
border where she kind of kneels down and
she's crying
and they kind of replaced it with her
watching the tv of the capitol riots and
that means going around viral right now
because again you have to understand
here you know she also
interjected this is not that she just
talked about it randomly offhand
she interjected when people were having
a populist reddit revolt on
on wall street with the wall street bets
she interjected that with
this particular story which we're
learning is just
absolutely nonsensical so ask yourself
was it spontaneous
was it deliberate was it intended to
bring attention back to the fact that
there's been an insurrection and there's
domestic terrorists and she's
getting out in front now messaging for a
roll out
of counter insurgency and counter
domestic terrorism and censorship
and censorship all kinds of things she
has to keep the story alive keep the
emotion alive
to to to lay down some groundwork for
legislation and action did you also
happen to notice today
that npr and reuters both running
stories from brennan saying
that we need to to take the lessons that
we learn from battling
insurgents in iraq and afghanistan and
use those same tactics here
against people in the united states npr
was running that story interviewing a
cia
agent that was a part of fighting
counter insurgency
in the middle east and he's like we need
to do this we need to go after trump
it's crazy he literally said this former
cia guy to npr
that we have to treat the people who
follow trump like isis or al-qaeda
npr by the way national public radio not
a national company it's a private
company right to nonprofit i believe
yeah but uh they're now going to start
bringing the domestic
the war on terror home domestic glenn
greenwald warned about it of course
and i i love it i love it but no no no
i'm saying i love the media scenario you
gotta let me finish
i love that all of a sudden you now have
these
leftists who claim to be
anti-authoritarian
suckling the teat of the security state
and cheering it on
cheering for 25 000 troops coming to d.c
cheering for a
permanent green zone barbed wire
defenses surrounding the capitol
cheering for 5 000 national guard
permanently remaining
in dc cheering for aoc as she
manipulates
and tells these hoax stories in order to
generate the ability
to swing public opinion to generate the
swing in public opinion to support
more authoritarian lockdown the
tactics that they learned in iraq and
afghanistan to manage
an insurgency are things like this hire
local gangs to carry out assassinations
use bribery and intense intense uh
incentives use drone strikes in the
middle of the night
like just make people disappear we also
have to understand
this insane notion of an insurrection
when the united states went there
to their country they're not
insurrecting against anything they're
mad about guys coming into their country
and then killing their people
and then dropping drone bombs on them so
so how dare you even call them
insurrectionists they're people who are
fed up who are wearing flip-flops who
don't even know where the united states
is or even the concept of the united
states most of them talk about
afghanistan yes
yes i mean it's absolutely insane to
understand you know the situation in
afghanistan from my personal friends who
are vets
who are saying a lot of these guys don't
even know anything about the united
states they don't even care about what
we do
they just want to live their life and
most of them are goat herders i want to
point out the united states
is an insurrection against the british
monarchy let that be remembered
started or so but let me read the story
from the from red state they say
newsweek even claimed that aoc they said
this
ocasio-cortez said that rioters actually
entered her office forcing her to take
refuge inside her bathroom
after her legislative director geraldo
bonilla chavez told her to hide hide run
and hide
and so i run back into my office she
said okay said
i slam my door there's another kind of
like back area to my office and i open
it and there's a closet in the bathroom
and i jump into my bathroom it turns out
however
that wasn't true they had to fact check
and start retracting all this because it
wasn't true
they say as it turns out however my
colleague banshee reported earlier aoc
said in her instagram drama that the
person who came to her office was a
capital police officer
but she denigrated the officer who came
to help claiming he didn't feel right
and that he was looking at her in all
this anger and hostility they going to
mention
but a few important things to note that
seem to have been left out of the whole
story
aoc wasn't even in the capitol building
where all the action was going down
if she was in her office she was in the
cannon building which is nearby but a
different
building but of course many didn't get
the logistics and just assumed that she
was
in the capitol building according to rep
nancy mace a republican from south
carolina
who has an office in the same hall as
aoc two doors away there were never
any rioters in their hall so there was
never any physical danger from the
riders coming in at any point
aoc tells this story making it seem like
the rioters are coming
taking advantage of the fact that people
don't know where her office is
not in the capitol building and in
response we see this from her
she said all right let me let me slow
down jackpot tweeted aoc he
tweeted the story aoc wasn't in the
building aoc responds
this is the latest manipulative take on
the right they are manipulating the fact
that most people don't know the layout
of the capital complex
we are we were all on the capital
complex the attack wasn't just on the
dome
the bombs trump supporters planted
surrounded our offices too
aoc took advantage of the fact that
people didn't know they didn't know
when she said oh the rioters and i was
hiding my office most people just
assumed
her office was in the capitol building i
did i did too i did too
she was so proud because she was telling
the story about the riots and everything
i assumed that she was in this building
when it's when when it turns out
it's not true and she was lying she says
we're the ones
or or jack pasovic or the right are the
ones manipulating
so here's what jack posobik tweeted a a
picture from google maps
here's the u.s capitol building and then
you can see cross the street and you
have
katie porter's office and then you have
the that's in the
longworth house office building across
the street from that is the cannon house
office building where aoc is
she was kitty corner to the capitol
building in a different
building they didn't go in the tunnels
they went into the capitol building
when jack pointed this out ao said you
were what about the tunnels
they weren't in the tunnels we know they
weren't in the tunnels that wasn't the
news story
so it's a month later and she comes out
with another story i'll mind you
conveniently around the time that people
are are staging and insurrection i'm
doing air quotes against wall street
and totally shifts the narrative and we
get to some stupid drama news cycle
where they're just like oh michael
tracy's a journalist and he said some
mean things about her
and the day goes by and everyone's like
you guys realize that she doesn't work
in the capitol building right
and then i didn't i didn't i didn't
bother to look into the story you know
why
i didn't care to cover it who cares yeah
it's silly drama so she was scared
look like i mentioned aoc comes out and
says i was scared i say i respect that
look i'm i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
look jack you're you're at six foot five
or whatever
if you told me that you you know you
weren't scared i'd say sounds about
right and aoc is you know like what five
seven
and she's like a you know just she's
she's not no experience in this kind of
situation
i say okay she's scared can we move on
what's the point no no no use arguing
whatsoever
but my question to you guys do you think
that she just spontaneously sat down and
started weeping on instagram
or do you think that this was
intentional i think she's associated
always intentionally well this is the
thing
this is not part of a larger issue this
is this is what we have to remember
she also was photo opt crying at a fence
looking at an empty parking lot a couple
months ago that's very true so
i mean the photo's very clear it was at
the immigration camps
there wasn't anything there it was an
empty parking lot and she's weeping and
crying and those photos went viral and
there was big stories about this and
this is
again rinse and repeat use emotion in
politics to skew
anyone's rational thinking and critical
thinking skills which are out the door
because
we have a lady that's crying we have to
do our
what is it called we have to we have to
you know white knight as best
i love the meme where it's like a
crudely drawn paintbrush meme and it
says oh no she's crying quick burn the
constitution
that's the only way when i say it's
always intentional what i mean is when
you make internet videos they're
you're always doing it on purpose you
never like accidentally in your in your
most vulnerable state
get online and make an internet video
it's it's a process
yes and we've seen a ton of youtubers do
this where they start
they start filming themselves and
they're like i'm just so sad and i
needed to tell you all it's like
you turned the camera on and then
started crying for the camera like
breakup videos they're so annoying
aoc has really like taken this new
internet drama culture of reality tv
much like trump did from
from terrestrial television bringing it
into politics she's bringing
the same kind of drama garbage nonsense
reality tv from the internet
into the political world and it is gold
it's platinum i'm afraid it's driving
her kind of crazy i went through it as a
youtuber when
and then with the things you think they
love you for you want to do more of and
if
you think they like you because you're
crazy you want to be crazier and then
you want to be crazier and like try and
top yourself
and to see that in a politician is
terrifying i think she knows what she's
doing i think she's a careerist i think
that's why i'm like i don't care to talk
about her telling her story the fact
that she's now jesse smalletted
everybody
and we all just assumed she was in the
capitol building that's
that's huge imagine if she went through
what rand paul went through a couple
days ago when he went through a black
lives matter
protest you rand paul i was there i
saved him
yeah we have rand paul at like two
o'clock in the morning i was out on the
protest it was the night of the
republican national convention and they
didn't have any security out in the
street and i spent all night
escorting people from the the convention
from the white house back to their
hotels
guiding them around rioters and mobs and
stuff and as i was getting ready to
leave there was rand paul and i went up
to him like dude you can't be here
and we bought some time in space and we
finally got some cops over there
he got attacked he got attacked because
they said why won't you support brianna
taylor when he's literally the guy who
wrote the the
undertale bill yep he wrote it but they
assume like it's a republican get him
yeah it's like it's rand paul dude no
they don't like them they don't care
yeah
aoc comes out and talks about you know
the first criticism she got for the
story
from a lot of people was i wonder what
the people who lost family members
during the black lives matter riots are
thinking right now when you're claiming
that you know you were scared for your
life but think about how
how despicable this is now not only
are you know look i don't like these
games where they're like
well the black lives matter you know
riots did all this damage so you should
be talking about them
i don't like that you know why they're
different things aoc is allowed to be
like yo i was scared
it has nothing to do with what happened
with black lives matter if you're mad
that she
she didn't call it out we can say i i'm
so sorry this happened to you like i
mean it sincerely
it's a horrible thing and uh i'll get
your back
my only my only request is just to pay
attention to other people who feel this
who feel similarly i don't think it's a
one-up game but now i'm pissed
because now it's not only does she
defend well protests are supposed to
make people uncomfortable not only does
kamala harris bail out these riders who
burn down cities
literally got people killed aoc now
fabricates the story of of you know what
went down
well i actually have uh uh one tweet
where someone actually points out that
aoc even changed her story
day over day where first she was saying
that she didn't go to the extraction
point
because she was worried about the other
congress people and i did a big segment
about this on my main channel
about how the democrats are scared
republicans will kill them because aoc
was saying i'm worried about what
they'll do to me
she was telling how you know during the
capital riots i didn't want to go with
the republicans and be in the same place
with them
later she's now saying that maybe she
didn't get the extraction point
information because the officer was
withholding it
like the story changed a month later she
is purposefully turning on her live
stream
and telling a sob story my question is
you brought you bring up a good point
jack
why why is she bringing this up right
now it's been a month
and she goes they're trying to tell me
to move on i'm not telling you to move
on i'm wondering why it is you
purposefully chose to start a late night
prime time live stream telling a fake
story
exaggerating what went down and
denigrating the cop who actually tried
to save your life
if it was true that you were in the
capitol building like everyone assumed
and maybe it's not her fault because
people just assumed it but that could be
it's a manipulation tactic to leave out
key details to make people assume things
i don't know if she has the savvy to
actually pull that off maybe she does
but i think she does i think she's
extremely cynical i don't think people
give her enough credit i think we think
she's silly and ditzy
i think she's incredibly cynical and the
fact that she brought in the like the
race of the people who are being
affected like treating the cop like he
was after her because
her skin tone like that's something uh
intense for when you're feeling super
emotional
if she's telling us this story about
riders coming to get her it was bad
enough
she was insulting the cop who was
risking his life to save or when another
cop
already lost his life now it turns out
this cop was probably just walking
through an empty building
and he probably knocked on the door
probably not even that bad and said oh
where is she
oh she you can come out what's go go to
the go to go to katie porter what's up
with the bombs i heard about bombs
surrounding yeah there were
there were pipe bombs i guess right now
okay she never said she was in the
capitol building
in from what i know so she didn't
overtly lie to people she just omitted
information
assuming that people knew no no but now
she's saying when jack bosobic put out
the story
she's like this is misinformation they
don't understand the capital complex
she's trying to defend the idea that she
was saying and the mainstream media was
running with the story she was at the
capitol
many of them and if if you're in that
position you're supposed to fix them
you're supposed to correct them as the
person who's telling the story
so people don't assume but not only that
she may not have said i was in the
capitol building
she was telling a story about how the
rioters were potentially coming for her
and she was hiding from them
they weren't they were across the street
in a totally different building no she
it was just madness and chaos so she
didn't know where they were
likely she knew they weren't in the
building and when you say if you're at
the capitol complex you're at the
capitol
even if you're not in the capitol
building you're still at the capitol is
the way i think
the phrase it's irrelevant bro look look
i i was i wasn't at the capitol building
that day but i was downtown i was on
pennsylvania avenue i saw what was going
on i felt the energy
dude even i could tell that there was
something off right there was energy in
the air that wasn't usually there and it
was unsettling to me and as i get into
reports of the riots at capitol i was
like i'm not i'm not going down there
so i can understand if she was
uncomfortable i totally can
the lying i even understand that people
embellish
she's on instagram she's talking her
heart and whatever
but the timing and why
now why now at the same time as all this
news about domestic counter intelligence
or counterterrorism
and battling insurgencies and doubling
down on people being terrorist groups
and insurgents and and suppression of
civil rights and coming after people and
detrompification
i think it's smokescreen i think it's
meant i mean it's meant to get us to do
this like why didn't she talk
around and talk about it instead of like
being more focused on what
the cia and the fbi and everybody are
going to do but i disagree we talked
about the other day we're literally
talking about the cia and the fbi
in this context and how it's dangerous
that aoc's emotional story which is
fabricated
is a manipulation tactic that will allow
the the federal government to expand
national security
powers and shout out to rashida tolay
once again for for being the one person
that says we can't allow the government
to expand their their security powers on
this
meanwhile aoc is the one who's feeling
the fire to do it do you think that that
signifies a crack in the squad you know
honestly i i look back
at a lot of the news and i don't i don't
know if rashida tula was always
completely in alignment more so that
they were kind of fellow travelers in a
sense
that uh their interest aligned for a
time for the time being
and uh i i'm not gonna be able to pull
up all of the other examples where i've
been like oh that's interesting that
richard delayed wasn't agreeing with abc
on this one but notably the omnibus
spending bill
where she played voted against that and
so did tulsi gabbard and i said wow
that's really cool rashida delayed that
was the right move
more republicans voted no on it tulsi
gabbard voted no on it i wish
you know more people voted no on it what
would be amazing is to have her on the
show
so if anyone knows her it has
connections to rashida talib
please come down please message us we
would love to have you and i think that
would be an awesome amazing important
thing i've
probably said some very disparaging
things about her in the past like
very critical i'm pretty i'm pretty much
we'll be fair like we are to everyone
else but
she's obviously you know providing a
perspective that's very critically
important
and for a wider audience to understand
that i think is critical right now
i look at what aoc is doing as extremely
destructive
and the drama politics the snapback
clapback stuff
is really really bad for for our
political environment
it's got to be called that's got to be
talked about get used to it bro
oh i know i know i mean future it was
yes absolutely
it is it is reality tv politics is
idiocracy and trump is to blame for a
lot of it as well
but trump didn't create it aoc didn't
create it it's
it's a natural byproduct of humans
just their love for drama i actively
tried to create it in 2007.
youtube video blogs talking about
becoming the president using internet
video to interact where you don't need
secret service you can have
leaders from around the world on skype
together and
but we're not talking about talking
about barack obama getting them up as
the first internet president but that's
not what
we're talking about what we're talking
about is instead of saying
let's do a live show where the president
can talk to the constituents about new
healthcare policy
it's more like i'm running for the
democratic party because jack murphy's
a [ __ ] burn yo high five me luke yeah
jack what do you got to say to that i
just roasted you on tv vote for me
there's gonna be a lot of that and i
think that trump and aoc are similar
in that both of them this is my take are
following their instincts
and it's not uh as proactive and
deliberate as my as people might ascribe
to them
uh i don't give either one of them that
much credit i just think that they're
being themselves
going with the flow feeling the energy
right i mean social media people you
know what the energy's like
you put something out you get the energy
back you're like oh i do just like
you're saying you do
you do more of that like i know exactly
what kind of topics get
high engagement for me on twitter i know
which ones that don't
i still do ones that don't because it's
true to me
but if you're just following the energy
it's it's a it they're
it's bro it's being drawn out of them as
well
for you you're right for aoc and and for
trump
you know trump would tweet up a storm
and he'd switch like we long talked
about how there would be some drama
or a lawsuit for instance there's a
really funny moment where trump changed
the asylum rules
and it was the one time no one cared
about trump's moves towards like
immigration why
because he tweeted the squad should go
back to where they came from
and then come back or whatever trump
knew he could tweet and shift the focus
away from the things he was working on
and he did
you're right i think aoc knows how to
generate press attention
gain more followers you got 12.2 million
and
i think for uh channels like this look
you're gonna you're you'll get a lot of
grifters people who
similarly know what they can talk about
in order to generate a ton of press
dude we we'd all be better off playing
minecraft
doing scare vlogs you know like jump
scares and pranks
it does it does so much better and so
it's it's weird to me that there are
people who are grifters who choose
politics as their as their path
really because it's like bro you could
just make minecraft videos
and do better if you applied yourself in
the same way the hard work you would be
the biggest video game
fortnite you know call of duty whatever
channel you streamed it
politics is not where you want to go for
this stuff politicians however
it's exactly the game they have to play
and then they need
other people to pop them up so there is
an element when it comes to
political commentary from left or right
of propping up the politicians they like
and trying to win some political battle
but i truly believe that right now the
space we are in
has nothing to do with politics that's
why they say you know tim poole is far
right or whatever even though i'm like i
like universal health care with
with with private supplemental insurance
that's a right-wing position apparently
but it's because i'm critical of their
tribe
so it's really just tribal politics
that's right aoc
can lie and be caught and they will
defend her
and say you're far right now truth be
told
donald trump even said he could shoot
someone on fifth avenue and not lose a
voter
because it was it was very tribal now
truth be told i think
in in the precursor to this new era
trump was pushing policies people liked
and because of that he generated a large
tribal base which expanded
into a tribal base specifically but a
lot of people supported trump
on his policy notably i did i voted for
him because of school choice because
of his later attempts to withdraw from
afghanistan and the abraham accords etc
but now what i think we're going to be
moving into as trump leaves with aoc now
getting 12.2 million followers
is going to be absolute drama
youtube style she'll make a video being
like you know ted cruz
he was saying this ted cruz i challenge
you to a rap battle and then ted cruz is
going to come out and be like yo aoc
what up let's rap and it's going to get
ridiculous
not really ted cruz ted cruz is already
playing basketball
with jimmy kimmel boom there you go so
it's already happening it's already here
and
the the bastardization of just the media
space
just to get the clicks just to get the
attention just to get the paris hilton
pr
model running which is essentially what
we're on and again we have to look i
i've been saying this i sound like a
broken clock
it's a lot to do with the algorithm
sound like a broken
i had to laugh at that potato potato you
know what i'm trying to say here yes
uh i have to laugh at myself here
again uh where we're going to is just
idiocracy times 10 but i think a lot of
this is incentivized by the big tech
algorithms the big tech oligarchs who
are
controlling what we see controlling
what's popular controlling what we don't
see and i think that perspective is
is essentially really really critically
important moving forward because that
power
is everything like the cortez obviously
had this moment where she was like i'm
feel i know that the robin hood thing
scandal is going on i know that i could
talk about the sec in the banking
industry getting involved with wall
street
and messing up these people's but i'm
feeling this so i need to talk about
what i'm feeling and that is
very selfish you don't have to talk
about what you're feeling
sometimes you want to not talk about
what you're feeling and talk about other
things that are more important
yeah if you're a representative you're
supposed to represent other
people not just yourself and talk about
yourself and be
self-censored and egotistical when
you're supposed to be talking about the
suffering of
all the other people who are not doing
good who are downtrodden who are being
screwed over time and time again whose
wages are going down
whose wealth is going down all because
of a broken system that
you're now literally taking selfies in
front of being like
well don't i look pretty aoc is little
trump yeah
i should say for a long time the people
who follow her aren't cheering on her
policies because what are her policies
green new deal explain to me what the
green new deal is i mean literally
because i'm in favor of a green new deal
no joke
i did a whole video on on it two years
ago when aoc was talking about green new
deal i was like this is actually really
cool
and i pulled up a poll that said 85
percent of people support the idea of
green new deal
you know why the simple way of
describing a green new deal
should the government allocate more
resources into
investing in developing and expanding
renewable energies
yeah what do you what do you think jack
yes agree i agree with that do you think
so luke
you're against texas i i don't like any
government doing anything so
85 of people are like absolutely look
understanding existing in this con the
confines of the existing
existing taxation system the us
government has tons of our money
and we think they should allocate more
towards green energy renewal projects
and things like that expanding
technology investing
so linger was a disaster but people are
still like hey mit look man we're trying
to do something cool and good and new
instead we get four and eight packages
in the billions of dollars trillions of
dollars
and aoc's green new deal what is it well
according to scikat chakrabarty her
former chief of staff it has nothing to
do with the environment it's all about
re reshaping the u.s economy it was
about creating
gender studies programs it was about
getting guaranteed college for people of
color
had nothing to do with the new deal with
renewing look we got crumbling bridges
and crumbling roads
crumbling infrastructure and we want to
help push america towards
more energy independence and what i
should say is more advanced energy
independence to secure our position as
an energy independent nation yeah i like
the idea of the investment
what aoc proposes isn't that so i look
at what people are talking about with
aoc and they can't
what are they really supporting did she
did she force nancy pelosi to
to put a floor vote on medicare for all
no she just blindly voted for her
she's not doing anything to actually
help progressives other than be a tribal
avatar
for the for for the tribe and what is
she calling for she's calling for big
tech censorship she's calling for the
eroding of civil liberties she's calling
for a bigger
police states that of course will of
course reign in on supposed domestic
terrorism threats where she's talking
about a new patriot act
2.0 i mean these are policies that of
course go completely against
helping individuals what actually does
help people well it's none of the
policies that of course
aoc is pushing right now in my opinion i
think it seems to me it seems to me that
there's an algorithm we're not talking
about right now and it's the one that's
in our head
we have an algorithm we are pre
determined to react to certain things
she is hacking our human algorithms much
like trump did much like trump
much like anybody who's successful
social media in a competition for
attention
it's the attention economy you got to
get attention how do you get attention
you appeal to people's emotions
you put that out there you trigger those
empathetic reactions and the byproduct
of getting attention
in a positive way because there is
positive ways of doing it
but the byproduct of doing this is we're
just splitting into these empathetic
tribes
you you can watch the same thing with
two different people
you take away two different outcomes two
different perspectives
and you can't understand at all what the
other person is saying
i read i tweeted something about this
today jack vasobic retweeted me so i got
i got the jacksobic tidal wave of
comments and he has a lot of haters
bro and the people that were responding
and the hate the hate camp
man they can't see it and they think
that we're all just monsters and devils
and terrible people because because we
think she's manipulating us
here's what i love so uh there's this
big battle going on between marjory
taylor green
you know and and and the democrats they
want her removed from her committees for
things she has said previously that are
fairly you know insane and bombastic
don't get me wrong
and uh it was reported that you know
kevin mccarthy minor
minority leader in the in the house was
negotiating with her to like take her
off one committee
i just responded with republicans are
such pathetic losers
now think about the context of that
kevin mccarth democrats demand
marjorie taylor green be removed from
all committees but kevin mccarthy says
only one
and then i called republicans pathetic
losers
the immediate assumption from a bunch of
these leftists was why are you defending
marjorie taylor green
and i said what did i say in her defense
it's a it's a tribal assumption
what what if the what if my point was
that
instead of just booting her off for
committees the republicans were
only were refusing and and cow towing to
q and on
and that's why i was calling them
pathetic losers i just called them
losers
and immediately the tribal assumption
was i was in defense
of marjorie taylor green i don't mean
not i don't mean to call out your
methods but you
do tweet those vague mirror
projecting tweets all the time you mean
like
vague like as in it's like the magic
mirror it's like
yes it's like whatever people respond
reveals the way they interpreted it
literally why i didn't yeah yeah
and it's it's effective but the truth
was i don't care if the republicans kick
off committees or don't regardless
they are pathetic losers they're
republican politicians so i was like i
don't care indeed
i i figured it was something everybody
would agree with
right either you're a republican who
says why are they coming after marjory
taylor agreement and bowing down to the
democrats
or you're a democrat saying why won't
they remove this crazy woman either way
they're spineless pathetic losers who
can't just make a decision
they're like what do we do what if we
only hurt her a little what if only you
stripper
a little bit it's like pick one dude
either you're with the democrats and
you're saying she's bad
or you stand over people who just got
elected to your party spineless
i don't care if they keep her under they
don't keep her on i think she said crazy
stuff
and i understand why people are mad
about it i think there's been democrats
have said crazy stuff maybe
margery taylor green said some crazy or
crazy or stuff online regardless
pick one they can't even do that who
whose side are they on
you know the republicans just love to do
whatever they're told
in a very pathetic and weak way it's
it's it's it's
fairly sad but uh but no you bring up a
good point
i almost always make these magic mirror
tweets as you call them
the goal is whatever tribe someone's on
they see what they want to see and it's
hilarious to watch them react to it
i just i i you know i gotta say i it's
michael malus man i learned from the
best
yeah but i didn't come up with this
stuff it's hilarious to like kick over
an ant hill and watch the ants scramble
kind of you mess up you must understand
yeah but he's not destroying anything
oh you're like finding joy in their in
their suffering and confusion
who's suffering these people that are
answering i genuinely think
i genuinely think that republicans are
pathetic spineless losers
and i kept it fairly vague so that it
wasn't
overtly descript towards a particular
individual like you also made a video
about it where you went deeper into it
i think about what uh you you led a
video i heard you lead a video earlier
today
republicans are spineless losers you
actually called them losers in a video
absolutely and that was a way for you to
explain it but in the tweet
it's it's on it's like a vague and
people are freaking out and so what
well it seems like you enjoy watching
people freak out i don't look at the
tweets i don't go and check what people
are are saying responsibilities
you just say the most part the people
you did was talking about the response
yeah it was a guy who said who was
immediate response to me after i tweeted
it was
like you know you are clearly supporting
marjory taylor so weird because i
completely stopped doing that
doing vague tweets i'm trying to be as
specific
in tweets as possible so that i don't
confuse people it's no no no it
you it's impossible it's literally
impossible people will just tweet nasty
things for no reason i mean look at seth
rogen
do you see the seth rogen jonathan k
interaction jonathan k
who uh he's at isn't he yeah jonathan k
is uh i don't know i'm not super
familiar with what his exact title would
be but he writes for quillette
and he tweeted a joke about something do
you remember what it was jack
i don't know it was shampoo oh yes
that's right he was using
so he tweeted this joke it was a silly
little joke where he was like for the
longest time i've been using dog shampoo
and didn't realize until i went to the
store
and tried to buy it and then notice in
big bold letters it says pet shampoo and
i should have realized
and seth rogen responded with like
you're stupid something like that
and he responded with like okay i'm is
making a silly joke because of
self-deprecating humor and seth rogen
was like so what i said you're stupid
that's that's that's the point of
twitter that's why you don't use twitter
legitimately
no matter what you say you passively
make a joke where you are deriding
yourself in silly humor targeting no one
and a a multi-millionaire celebrity will
will insult you for no reason
it's free none whatsoever so i don't
give specific
tweets i see the republicans i see what
they're doing instead of me writing out
500 paragraphs explaining everything
wrong with republicans i say these
people are spinal
spinals losers they won't stand up for
anything they don't defend anything
they just say well we'll do a little bit
of what you want democrats and then not
do anything not all of them right
99 yeah you got thomas max is cool ran
paul's cool
josh hawley's pretty cool uh uh ted cruz
is okay
you know that's pretty cool well i
disagree with dan crunch on a lot of
things but i think he's an all right guy
i just really
disagree with him on a lot of things see
i just post a bunch of memes and
we have to we have to remember social
media is not real life but it's becoming
real life and
a lot of the nastiness is incentivized
again
by the algorithm when you do have that
drama when you do have that thing again
we're talking about this again from the
very beginning it's all about emotions
if you're able to spark a negative one
they've done psychological studies
showing that gets more of your attention
that that spurs the fight-or-flight
uh reflexes and uh here we are you know
we're dude we're talking about the same
thing
there so i used to work for these
non-profits this is uh now
almost 14 years ago i did fundraising
for nonprofits and it was street
canvassing
you guys know those people on the street
that are waving to you saying like you
have a minute talk about the environment
or whatever that you don't want to have
eye contact with yes
yes because if you have eye candy they
got you yeah yeah but you know
i'll tell you guys a secret technique
you know the secret technique is i could
get anybody in the world to stop for me
anyone in the world you wanna know what
the trick is break dancing nope
trip them you don't ask them anything
you just hold out your hand
you walk up to him stand in front of him
and hold out your hand and shake it and
then once you're shaking your hand you
say i'm going to talk to you about the
environment why are you happy it's the
same way if you meet a girl and you want
to get
no no no no no you're off with physical
contact that's not it it's that i'm
physically holding them and they can't
leave and then you get pepper there's
there too
but i'm shaking their hand you see it's
a clever hi
sales tactic that came out a little
psycho what i said you grab their hand
and you shake it
and they can't walk away while you're
talking to them and then with your other
end you hand them your clipboard they
grab it
and then you let go and then you put
your hands you you you hold your hands
to your side
now they're physically holding your
property they'll try and hand it to you
but they can't they can't leave as long
as they're holding it anyway i digress
when i worked at these offices they
would have these ev these events where
they would mass
purge the entire office firing 40 to 50
people in a single day
because demoralization is like a virus
so you have 40 or 50 people and you need
them doing sales
for a cause which means they have to be
passionate and positive
they go out in the street and they say
dude i need your help right now we gotta
save the world man
i believe in you do you believe in me
let's do this give me your credit card
now how much we're gonna tell how much
money i'm taking from you
so getting people to feel good was was
paramount there's also also ways where
you can make people feel
regret or or loss and make them
feel a sense of urgency to get them to
donate but what happens when this
when the when the fundraiser the
canvasser can't do it
they get frustrated they get really
close to that sign up that membership
and they fail
now they're getting frustrated and angry
they try again but that frustration
persists
now the people who are walking up to
this angry person with a furled brown
they're like i don't want to talk to you
you're nasty and pissed off
that person comes back to the office
their friends say how was your day it
was awful dude people are such awful
people i hate this place
and then the other people feel that
negativity the negative negativity start
to spread like a virus
so all of these offices what they would
do is they would have no joke 40 to 50
people in the office all
training and they would do debriefs at
the end of every day when people come
back to the office and
then they would ask you how was your day
if too many people said negative things
they would immediately fire every single
person
to stop the spread of the negativity
virus you're making me think and then
re-hire an entirely new team in the next
week the negativity viruses in congress
oh absolutely but it's on social media
and it can't unless we get rid of all of
them it's going to persist no i'm not
talking about it
i still have it i'm talking about
twitter new people go in like aoc
she got it you have people who are
overtly negative being negative to other
people
spreading around a negativity
demoralization
mind virus so one of the stories i like
to tell is about how i was getting a cab
from new york i was in manhattan
as people in new york know this new york
abbeys
in manhattan will not go to brooklyn
because they got crazy rules yellow cabs
can't pick people up in brooklyn green
cabs don't pick people up in manhattan
so if you're in manhattan cabbie pulls
up what they'll do is they'll crack
their window a little bit
and then they'll say where are you going
if they're not allowed to do this it's
illegal you'll say brooklyn and they'll
peel out
so you got to say you got to give them a
fake address or something get in and
then it says you're in there go oh
actually i mean brooklyn and they get
really mad
well so i had a cab pic pick me up and i
didn't lie to him he just pulled over i
got in the car he said where are you
going i said i'm going to williamsburg
and he got really angry and the entire
ride from manhattan to brooklyn which is
a decent ride
he was just driving like like a jerk he
was cussing he was angry complaining i
gotta drive
brooklyn and just mad at me the whole
time and i didn't say anything to him
and then when i got out of the car i
gave him 100 tip
i doubled the money and as i'm as the
receipts printing
all of a sudden he just like was like oh
they
thank you thank you so much bless you
bless you and your family
and i was like hey man i i really
appreciate you taking the time out of
your day to bring me to brooklyn i know
you can't pick people up so hopefully
this gets you back to
to keep working and i hope that you you
know bring a positive light to the you
know
other people because now that guy feels
bad for one about being mean to me
because i hooked him up
but more importantly i wasn't trying to
make him feel bad he's happy
he's like dude i was i was in for a bad
day and this dude just covered the cost
of my trip back to manhattan here's the
point
the next person who gets in that vehicle
is going to see a smiling happy guy
who's going to be like don't worry about
it buddy i got you today it's a good day
so rather than trying to combat the
negativity you let them be angry
and then still give them positivity you
create a positivity mind virus
you spread the joy this guy who was
angry at me i could have been angry at
him i could have said you know what no
tip for you because you were mean
and then i was like oh get out of my
screw you then the next person who gets
in that cab is going to be like hi i'm
just getting off of work and he's like i
don't care where you're going and dude
why you mad at me now
now that guy the passenger is going to
get angry i don't want to spread that
mind that evil that anger that rage
i was like this guy was mean to me but
you know what it's not about me
it's what the next person is going to
get in this cab having a bad day so i
want this guy to have a good day
i don't know why he's mad maybe
something bad happened to him maybe he
lost his son maybe he stubbed his toe
whatever
here's a good day for you buddy i hope
this changes things and makes you feel
better
and now he has a good day and he spreads
that good day to others
social media is full of negativity mind
viruses
so i try very hard very often to have
semi-neutral or just like non-direct
tweets at individuals
i don't like tweeting it people saying
very direct and harsh things i don't do
that because all it does is spread that
mind virus
and that's why when i had that moment
with frank luntz the pollster i simply
asked him a question he snapped at me
insulted me said i wasn't a journalist
i'm like dude what's with the hostility
man i just asked you a question like
what's wrong with people dude twitter
has created
a negativity demoralization hive mind
that everyone is getting sucked into and
it's making them nasty awful people
it's even bigger it's text communication
that's confusing people i think
well you know energy is contagious and
i'm surprised you don't know this
ian or you don't have a t-shirt that
says this your vibe like a t-shirt your
vibe is your tribe
so that you know we see a lot of hippies
saying this this is why i try to stay
usually as stupid optimistically as i
can because essentially it's a choice
and at the end of the day we all have a
choice where we invest
our energy and our mindset into and what
you bring up is critically important
because
when faced with negativity you could
either be you know
engulfed by it and represent it or you
could choose to defeat it back with
positivity so
i think the story that you shared i mean
you told you told me before a couple
years ago i think it's it's a very
important one that people should know
about
here's my advice to people you're on
twitter you're seeing people tweet
resist the urge at all costs to be mean
to them
if someone says something mean to you
say you know you know what i you know i
would say i say to people online very
often on facebook and these arguments
i'll say something and i'm never hostile
i'll try and actually be accommodating
and when they start insulting attacking
me i'll say i don't understand why
you're being so mean to me and you know
this is what i said yesterday you read a
super chat you were like it's a negative
one for you ian do you want to hear it
in retrospect maybe i'll say no don't
publicize those
but i had this urge to snap back and be
say something really mean
and and all that would have done is
tainted the night
and i didn't i just held it in i got a
lot of really nice comments today from
people
regarding that that experience so
there's another example of it
tim what you're talking about is
operating on a higher level of
mindfulness
right and and intentionality and that's
something that i want for everybody
intentionality is the superpower today
people who are conscious about where
they put their attention
their focus and their energy are going
to be more successful than people
happier more successful than people who
bob along the currents
right most of our country is sick
because they're bobbing along the
currents
they are fat and they listen to the
current of the nutrition pyramid they're
in debt because they listen to the
currents of going to school
they're slaves to a corporate wage job
because they listen
mindfulness and intentionality are a
superpower today now i want to just
share one story that is maybe a bright
spot here
you know when i tweet about antifa and
conflict and riots i get a ton of
engagement of course
when i tweet about my nerdy
philosophical philosophical stuff
i don't get as much engagement but it's
important to me so i do
but every so often i tweet about my kids
and i tweet about being a father and
stories of fatherhood
and stories of my son becoming a man and
the things that we've learned and taught
and
his experiences and i gotta tell you of
all the things that i've had go viral
and everything
it's the stories about my son growing up
as a man that have done the best
millions and millions and millions of
views tweeted all over like africa
i had like princes in africa like
responding like it just
bonker town millions and millions of
views famous famous in in my universe
there's snow shoveling threads and the
baseball threads and things like that
and even my pin tweet thread on my
profile it's been seen by millions of
people
it's a crazy story about positivity and
at the end people say that they're like
cheering
so there is certainly a vibe out there
that you can latch into a positive
energy of growth
there's a whole growth mindset twitter
out there i think perhaps
the political sphere on twitter is very
nasty
but there are subcultures and sub and
niches
all across twitter that are about
positivity they're about mindfulness
they're about parenting they're about
your values they're about finding people
that share your values so i agree i've
seen it
if i wanted to have 10 000 you know more
followers i tweet about riots and antifa
all day
uh but truly the stuff about my son
generates the most positive energy and
and it brings me the most joy as well
and that's usually something that that
we don't see that's usually something
that doesn't go viral but when it does
it's extremely powerful and there's a
there's a residency there's there's
something else more to it than
just you know the plain kind of text out
there and
and it's not just positivity one of the
things that i really wanted to bring up
is gratitude
i've been doing a gratitude journal
almost every day for eight years now
i write down five things i'm always
grateful for at the end of the day right
before i go to sleep just so i could you
know
you know hippies talk about
manifestation you know a lot of work
people
talk about creating uh especially in the
entrepreneurial sphere but but reminding
yourself hey we are extremely lucky we
are extremely blessed especially to live
in the western world especially to
i mean if you make thirty thousand
dollars you are pretty much the one
percent of the world you are yeah
so so when we look at it from that
perspective instead of the perspective
of what we're lacking of what we don't
have
we don't have the latest playstation 5
we don't have this this is the marketing
schemes
of these multinational corporations that
use these psychological tricks to make
you feel empty
to make you feel sad there was also you
know some of the things that i started
bringing up and looking into is just how
they do it there was even specific
restaurants that used to play sad music
whenever they had a dip
in business because they knew people
would get sad and what would they do
they would stuff their miseries with a
big cheeseburger
in their face so so these kind of
psychological tricks are
used on social media to extreme levels
and i think this is why we are seeing
depression
suicides self-harm and all these
negative mental health effects from
social media that are utilizing this at
a record level
and creating very severe consequences
that we're going to have to deal with
that that sadly there's no person that
could speak out against it because the
algorithm will downvote it
because the multinational corporations
won't be making any money off of it
the seth rogen aspect of the story is
really the craziest thing to me that you
could be
wildly successful funny guy on tv his
movies are always a laugh and a hoot and
a good time i'm a big fan
and then just see how like there's this
weird
i don't know negativity possession of
the man where he goes on twitter and
he's just
awful to people it's like he's just so
mean to me negative comedy
sometimes can sell if you say it in a
sarcastic way but it's when you're
you're vibing you're you know your voice
is vibrating the other people
when you write it down forget about it
but that's not a joke he just said
jonathan kay yours i could see his
character in a movie being like
you're stupid and you know like that
that's not the audience would be like oh
yeah but it's not a character
it's him it's a human being it's a
person it's a verified why is
him being a jerk why would someone who's
so extremely wealthy who could who could
do whatever and is so successful
just go on twitter and call insult
someone like that well i think it's i
mean tons of people do it's not just him
it's a good example that money and fame
certainly don't ensure happiness and
contentment or gratitude or mindfulness
or appreciation luke i want to go back
to something that you said a minute ago
about hippies talk about manifestation
well then call me a hippie dude because
i believe in manifestation i believe in
the power of personal narrative i
believe that the story that you tell
yourself
can change the world around you it
changes you it changes the way people
perceive you it changes the
opportunities that come your way
it changes the way you perceive the
universe and data and information
and the stories that we tell ourselves
are the most important thing
i live by one simple motto you are the
imagination of yourself
yes uh i believe it was who who said
that
um i think it was bill hicks bill hicks
is the one who who said it and explained
it best but but that
is something that i keep reminding
myself whenever i get too deep into the
whole political sphere whenever i get
into a negative
tailspin lydia you have something yeah
so i was actually reading a book just a
little while ago about stress by a lady
named kelly mcgonagall
she was talking about how stress will
shorten your life only if you think that
it's
bad only if you think that stress is bad
will it literally
shorten your lifespan if you view it as
a positive chance to develop yourself
it will make you stronger and better and
actually live longer yeah and it looks
amazing and in retrospect a lot of the
stuff that we're arguing about and
fighting about is absolutely petty
it's absolutely pointless it absolutely
doesn't even add up an
amount to anything it's just a lot of
egotistical grand
diesing in the inward kind of thinking
that that doesn't really produce
anything it just
destroys egotistical yeah i said that
i'm i'm a slavic person you better not
correct me on my speech
english is my second language and with
my new designation you better watch out
pal
i get banned on twitter so it's really
important to understand about the
counter and
uh terror stuff that's coming and all
the patriot act 3.0 and whatnot but but
personally
i'm more inclined to be thinking about
my values my personal values
and finding other people that share my
personal values and then getting
alignment
i don't know if you have alignment i
have alignment i have alignment where my
values
my mission my actions day-to-day my
purpose everything are perfect alignment
i don't need motivation man i am
weightless yeah i am invincible
i am drawn straight ahead across a
frictionless surface
towards my vision because i spent years
telling myself what it's going to be and
where i'm going to go and dreaming about
it
and constantly just shaping my reality
in order to make it happen
and now here i am yes the politics are
important yes we have to pay attention
yes bad things are coming but at the
same time it's more important than ever
right now to find people
who share your values and that's what
we're doing in the liminal order man
masculinity brotherhood sovereignty get
people together who share your values
come check it out
for a second what's that you created
people need to understand
uh when you're choosing your direction
when you're finding your destiny
there have been many moments in my life
where there have been very obvious
roadblocks that felt like if i go in
this path i am literally trying to push
against a brick wall it's not going
anywhere and there have been certain
moments where it just feels like you
said jack gliding across a
frictionless surface a lot of people
might have trouble figuring out how to
get that path rolling but i'll tell you
this when i first started doing
everything i was doing
i was homeless you know so so starting
at occupy wall street i know where to
live i was sleeping in a park
and i just did what felt right to do and
seemed
to just i don't know seemed to be the
thing to do and it didn't make a whole
lot of money and then eventually a
little bit of money came in
and then i was sleeping on a guy's couch
and then over time it's not like one day
i woke up and just signed a piece of
paper saying i'm gonna start a big
business and do a podcast
it's all just pieces that have been
added to the you know it's like building
a lego it's like you
a lego model or whatever you're adding
one piece every day
and eventually you have this big
sculpture or as as the statement uh the
the old adage goes the journey of a
thousand miles begins with a single step
you guys are talking about positivity
and negativity and alignment i see this
as like a physical
phenomenon literally protons are have
positive energy
electrons have negative energy you have
an electromagnetic field and when you
can balance these energy forces and with
neutral energy coming from the neutron
it will literally elevate you
magnetically off the earth you become
less weighted down by thoughts and
feelings which are like create packets
of dark matter that weigh you down your
thoughts you know
um i also think about the liminal order
i want to talk a little bit about
positivity and negativity because in
science protons are heavy electrons are
really light
it's really easy to attract negative
energy in science and i think
also in life um they but that's why it
spreads like a virus it is
it is and it's hard for people to
apologize
it's hard for people to resist when
someone's negative to you
they immediately want to react and be
negative back it's a process called
runaway breakdown in science that
is known for producing lightning you
have a cloud of plasma of electrons and
one will
go and then all the other ones will
follow it and it creates this shock of
electro
negative energy now negative energy can
also draw positive energy in and
positive energy can bring negative
energy so there is balance
and sometimes like when you go negative
and start talking about the deep
hate and the negativity things i want to
become positive to balance it out
there's that phenomenon too
so if you're only positive you may end
up have running into trouble and so it's
important to acknowledge these things as
well
what i do with negative energy is jiu
jitsu man
when i got doxed when i got fired when i
had my name tarnished and i went through
all that
and i lost my job and income my
reputation everything i had built for
years
you take all that negative energy and
turn it around
and now i use all that attention and all
that momentum to build an organization
values-based organization where men have
come together
with people who share their common
values to create that frictionless
surface in alignment and move towards
your goals in a way that's it's
basically effortless let's
let's let's talk about what's going on
with uh you mentioned the the cia the
domestic terrorist stuff because we have
this actual
big story from cnn canada will list the
proud boys movement as a terrorist
group that's that's the just the story
canada is now saying the proud boys are
terrorists
they say they'll be deemed an
ideologically motivated violent
extremist group along with three others
adam waffen the base
and the russian imperial movement of
which the proud boys don't necessarily
belong in that group at all
the government said in a news release
their violent actions and rhetoric
are fueled by white supremacy
anti-semitism racism homophobia
islamophobia and misogyny
and unfortunately often in combination
of all of the above
said public safety minister bill blair
at a news conference wednesday
i mean it's just factually incorrect
because as everyone knows ricky taro is
not a white man
when asked about the new terrorist
designation of the proud boys
for the proud boys blair said that the
events of january 6 at the u.s capitol
did initiate a political response in
canada
but that the decision was not political
quote and as a disturbing and concerning
as those images of those events were
they also provided law enforcement and
our intelligence services with a trove
of new information
in which quite frankly many of these
groups revealed themselves
said blair adding that canada's decision
was based on evidence intelligence and
law
my understanding proud boys don't really
operate all that much in canada
isn't that true i mean i haven't seen
anything i asked my audience today like
what did the proud
proud boys do in canada i mean i haven't
seen any protests i haven't seen any
attacks i haven't seen any actions or
consequences that have led to any kind
of human suffering
and now the out that that article
mentions three groups
the proud boys are now listed also with
al qaeda
the muhahajin and isis so
that's the designation that they give
the boys and you know whatever you think
about them like them or hate them
i think this is a stretch to say the
least and it's a very slippery slope
because they're essentially saying that
anyone could be a terrorist in the
future let's talk about what happens
next
uh i'm not going to name any specific
banks but there are many banks that are
international banks
they operate in the united states
they're very large some of the biggest
in the country and they operate in
canada as well
believe it or not though you know for a
lot of people who haven't traveled there
are a bunch of really crazy other comp
you know you got another country
and you'll see a bunch of different
banks you never heard of and that's okay
i mean it should be obvious but a lot of
people
are kind of surprised to see a bunch of
weird banks i never heard of but
in this current day and age it's really
interesting to see a lot of these banks
the same banks exist in a bunch of other
countries let's say you've
got some guy who's a proud boy in the
united states never been to a rally
never been to an event never been in a
fight
his bank calls him up and says although
in the united states you have a right to
free speech
and you have never been convicted of a
crime or charge of the crime or even at
a rally
in canada you are deemed a terrorist and
we operate in canada so we cannot
provide financial services to you
lest the canadian government come after
us so now if there is a company that
requires
any kind of government uh certification
or
permitting through canada for their
canadian arm they will come for you in
the united states
there are probably web services
especially that say well we operate in
canada as well like facebook for
instance
what happens now well canada's gonna say
we want you to ban all the terrorists
you cannot have facebook in our country
if you host terrorism
well now that the proud boys are
terrorists facebook will be like okay
what do we do do we ban them all and
then make it so that they're only banned
in canada
so when they post things doesn't appear
in canada or does facebook just start
banning them out right
i'm pretty sure for the most part
they've all been banned anyway
but now we're gonna start seeing how in
the us you may have rights
but thanks to the ever expanding
international corporate
system and international free trade
stuff
you could you can get some small island
nation with a decent amount of money
and they could say whatever they want
and then these big corporations if it
fits their fits the bill they're going
to be like okay cool ban them get rid of
them they're done
so yeah sure you'll be allowed to uh you
know live and function as you want but
what about visa and mastercard
visit mastercard operate in canada what
if canada says to them
you are providing financial services for
a terrorist organization so then visa
and mastercard in the united states tell
the proud boys anybody's ever been
associated
we're shutting you off from all credit
card services
that's that's that's it there's two
companies maybe go discover amex i guess
but what happens when those companies
say the same thing because they
operate internationally as well this
designation
is insane and we're gonna start seeing
just how bad this whole domestic war on
terror is gonna get
the babies are gonna get thrown out with
the bath water here i mean it's also
important to remember like if you
read the front page of the washington
post the last couple days
it reads the the copy reads as if there
was a planned
premeditated like domestic terror attack
a revolutionary attack that was planned
and implemented
and was successful and people are dead
and this is what they really
and truly believe in the minds of people
like aoc
there was a bunch of six foot five super
ripped dudes with night vision goggles
and
tactical gear storming and going move
move move now pull us his office run run
and then a bunch of cops came in and
fought him and it was this great battle
and then she's hiding in the bathroom
and the guy bangs with her boom boom
where is she and then she's like what's
happening
it's a cop and he goes get her out of
here and she's like oh no
no and that's that's how they're framing
it when in reality it was a bunch of
like bewildered bumbling fools and the
cops opened the door at one part
there was the storming of the central
door but the cops opened the door and
people are waving little flags and
walking in
and the cops are like oh that's your
right to protest one cop took a selfie
with people
in reality there was also individuals
that had
jackets with their phone numbers on the
back because of it
it was representing a construction
company that they had and i'm sorry
you know a lot of these masculist people
they're they're not criminal masterminds
uh they're they're not the sharpest
knives in the draw especially when they
have their phone number on the back of
their jacket
doing all of them or when the guy takes
the podium and then he smiles and waves
to the camera
there's no plan here but we we all know
this but the washington post puts it on
the front page that there was a battle
in the capitol and people are dead and
it was because we have terrorists in
america so
if you take that as the base which is
now history
right i tweet i tweeted a poll today i
said who won the battle of narratives
for january 6th
the commies are the good guys 80 90
the commies even our guys believe right
that they that we lost the battle of the
narrative for january 6
which is going to go down for all of
history which is now going to be the
linchpin
in the patriot act stuff and the in the
insurgents crackdown that's coming
and there's going to be a lot of
collateral damage and you know what
people aren't going to care
we have collateral damage obama obama
drops bombs on babies to get a terrorist
and guess what people say
collateral damage collateral damage i
don't think that the
that's too far away from where we are
here and i'm talking to
john robb uh next week who is an amazing
strategist technologists
he writes at the intersection of war and
politics and technology
he's been predicting this for some time
he's been predicting the fact
that there's going to be a corporate
techno fascism
rallying around an insurgency counter
insurgency development in the united
states
to just use that as the tool in the
vehicle by which just clamp down
on free speech human rights freedom
association freedom of movement
all of the things that we hold dear as
americans so really if you think about
it
they're framing us as insurgents you
know us
maga right term right side people it
it's it's kind of true
because we're occupied we're occupied by
people that don't believe in the
american spirit they don't believe
in american history they want to change
american history they don't care about
any of it
what does the second amendment say right
to bear arms shall not be infringed
bear is it bear yeah keep it okay keep
and bear arms yeah
what does it mean to bear arms open
carry
and in how many states are you not
allowed to open so many of course right
yeah it's just the constitution is
completely meaningless
it's gone i know it's gone and it's
going to get even worse it's going to
get even worse
and so uh you you wanna know what i'm
looking forward to though for the first
time to see a third amendment lawsuit
oh man what's that
no quartering in private homes of
military that one's never going to
happen it's just archaic and it's really
interesting that it was a big deal back
then
and it's not really been that big of a
deal for us in modern times but all the
rest of them especially the fourth the
fifth the first
second they're all huge even the ninth
the tenth i mean almost every amendment
i didn't even remember the third when
you brought it up just i was like wait
which one yep i love it yeah yeah the
soldiers can't be courted in private
homes
yeah i could see like if there was an
uprising an armed uprising and then the
people that were uprising would be like
we need to use your house we need to we
need to use your house and that could be
like a violation of people that was
basically what it was
you know back in the day the soldiers
would be like we're fighting a war and
so the soldiers are coming in we need a
place to stay so we're taking your home
not that the government would do it but
that our own people that were rising up
to protect us from the government would
try and do it
but these are these are pretty scary
times because we have thousands of
troops
inside of the u.s capitol we have
politicians we have the mainstream media
cheering on
the deep state arm of the intelligence
agencies large unaccountable departments
within our government
that are going after people for their
speech for
their beliefs and they're doing it more
and more aggressively
as we just learned that the fbi raided
the house of
rally organizers that organized a rally
on the night before january 6. now cnn
was
you know wrote a whole article about
this how this was justified because of
their
language but again these people weren't
charged
they just had their doors busted down
because they organized a political rally
now i don't know exactly what these
individuals said i don't even know who
they are
but but this is again an fbi that has
been mobilized and activated
and is becoming more and more political
when it came to individuals like epstein
they said on their hands they didn't do
anything for over 30
years 30 years so many horrible crimes
are happening with that individual
nothing but now you know we have this
insurrection they're mobilized they're
activated they're putting up wanted
posters all over the united states oh my
god
in every bus shelter in dc it's just all
these pictures of guys in maga hats and
just like do you know these people
all up and down my neighborhood all over
the place you know an additional scary
element to what's happening is not only
are they looking to prosecute people for
crimes today
not only are they looking probably into
the future to prosecute people for
anticipating crimes
they're going back five years they're
going back ricky going back five years
to ricky vaughn to get the guy for a
meme now
it it it's possible that it was actually
illegal and you can't tell people to
well wrong way to vote and whatever
but it was it was pretty bad what he did
uh so he so this guy uh he was you know
like a
an s poster i guess you want to call it
an issue poster and he had this
it was it was a viral meme that was
going around that said i i don't
necessarily think it's even fair to call
it a meme for the most part i know a lot
of people on the right have said that
it was like vote you know vote early and
vote by text
text this number avoid the lines yeah
avoid the lines text this number
and it said paid for by political
candidate so-and-so or whatever so it
was like
you can call it you can say it was a
joke and you go back i'm going to share
this
so i don't think the guy deserves to go
to prison for it well if he was trying
to trick people into thinking that
they'd voted that's pretty nasty federal
absolutely yeah it's crime yep and it
said that was paid for by the candidate
and that's that's hardman
trump didn't prosecute the guy so now
five years later
now michael hold on there's a bunch of
people who did the same thing on the
other side
identical there's a viral video of a
woman putting on a hat and saying trump
supporters go you know go here to vote
it was like totally fake
so the issue is trump didn't prosecute
any of those people now that democrats
are in power
they're going after the people who went
after them but not the people did the
same thing
so the scariest thing is going to be the
score settling
right yeah they're going to want to
settle the score
and that means that a lot of people who
thought that they were safe and a lot of
people who thought that they had
gotten away with it may not oh they
didn't no i mean it's going to get it's
going to be
it's going to be chaos look we've got
permanent
barbed wire fencing around the capital
right now the washington dc is currently
under occupation it is occupied by
the national guard and i'm not saying
it'd be bombastic literally 5000
national guard will be permanently
placed there so
i'm sorry they're saying the green zone
will be permanent i don't know how many
troops will be there
but they're saying at least until march
there's going to be 5 000 national
guardsmen you don't think that i mean
that is the central part of the iraqi
strategy
the green zone they've established the
green zone they're establishing their
counter-insurgency network
and it's pretty soon we're gonna start
seeing quiet bribes for assassinations
in the middle of the night
and drone strikes i mean i'm
exaggerating a little bit
or am i i don't know how far are they
going to go people that we know they're
rabid
they don't care about reality they don't
care about the constitution they care
about settling scores
they can't even be happy mike cernovich
the other day was tweeting out he's like
where is the jubilation from the
democrats right yeah they won
do you remember what it was like in
january of 2017. holy crap
that's why i met you was it the
deplorable too yeah like dude the energy
was insane everybody was ecstatic
there's none of that there's none of
that because they're negative nasty
they're still crying
yes this is the crazy thing when when
trump won
many we saw the memes of these people
dropping their knees and crying and
screaming and mourning
and the trump supporters were like what
they didn't think they were gonna win in
the first place so they're laughing and
celebrate good times come on all that
good stuff well joe biden did that one
at the at the at the uh uh wasn't the
price
the um i can't think of the word the dnc
at the convention um when he was
nominated
but after joe biden won
they were still crying yeah and i i
remember seeing like you mentioned
andrew sullivan was like listening to
biden's speech and started crying yeah
and i'm like they're still crying
because they summoned a demon to destroy
their enemy another demon's president
he's not a literal demon but it's like
when you use something you hate to
destroy something else you hate you're
still gonna end up hating it no but but
but
they like biden what i think happened is
they're infected with
a demoralization mind virus they wanted
trump out they didn't want by hand
let go of the hate and anger because
it's not it wasn't really about trump
it was just they just hate yeah and so
what happens now is they're redirecting
it towards this nebulous concept of
trumpism
which is meaningless they're saying now
they're gonna now they're saying oh
trumpism is the problem and
listen you're you you've got these
satellites orbiting this
planet trump was that planet that was
where all the media and all the
narrative and all that was orbiting now
the planet's gone
there's nothing to orbit anymore and so
they're pointing at
nothing trump so quickly disappeared
from public
the public spotlight no social media
haven't heard a word for the man outside
of these vague statements you get from
the office of 45 emails he's sending out
to people
where it's like here's my response to
impeachment yet they've still repeatedly
done stories
the daily beast this one journalist i'm
not going to say her name
ran a story saying trump lost the
presidency and twitter guess which one
hurt worse
and i'm like it's been two weeks trump
it's been um
longer than since trump's got suspended
from twitter okay
why are you still writing the same story
you wrote a month ago they were all
saying this
they're going to keep doing it because
they just hate
they need something to hate trump is the
avatar of their hate
but he's gone now so they just hate well
they're going to go after anything and
everything that they can
and to me what you're saying was
definitely exemplified by an
article that i saw from the independent
today that was titled
outrage as alleged capital rioter
is permitted vacation to mexico ahead of
trial and this whole article was doxing
this lady who was
again uh not convicted of a crime
doesn't have a criminal record
she had a work-related event that she
needed to go to mexico and a judge said
sure you could go to that
that's not true what never happened what
do you mean
news story broke uh and we saw a viral
trend on twitter white privilege
people were saying white privilege is
this capital rioter saying that she
wants to go on vacation and the judge
letting her do it never happened the
judge never issued an order saying she
was allowed to go on vacation ryan
reilly of the huffington post issued an
emergency correction saying everybody
everybody it never happened
it was a proposal not an order and the
media didn't fact check so they ran
and then the independent media ran with
it and then the independent
the independent ran with it and that's
that's the information that i got from
today i didn't see the correction i
talked about it and i read it i read the
full article today
this is what happens when you trust the
mainstream media luke yeah so you got me
i'm talking red-handed
they they they all ran the story
claiming that you know there was a
one high-profile left-wing commentator
showed a picture of a black man at the
riot who was
denied bail and he says i wonder what
about this man resulted in him getting
denied while this other story is
breaking hmm
well the other story is breaking is fake
news more importantly
this woman is being charged with i think
two misdemeanors disorderly conduct yes
and entering you know restricted grounds
apparently she'd even go in the building
and so she's getting a misdemeanor
charge which i tell you
when if when she goes in there and
they're like did you go on the grounds i
did your honor and
were you being disorderly well i
disagree but i accept the charges no
contest your honor is gonna be like okay
we're gonna give you 20 hours of
community service court supervision have
a nice day that's the end of it she's
going to go home and then they'll forget
forget it ever happened and then
mainstream media is going to freak out
about that and then also have another
rage bait click about this but
the larger point that i was trying to
make here is why is the independent
media the independent concentrating on
this lady
why you know it used to be where the
media used to go up against
special interest it used to go against
the powers that be it used to go up
against
actual people that actually mattered in
your life and had an effect on the way
you lived your life
they don't do that anymore it's it's
this lady that you have to be outraged
about look at look at what happened in
sweden i don't know if you know the
story jack but
uh several years ago you know i went to
sweden for this last name sweden thing
and one of the biggest stories i
discovered was that only a few months
prior
one of their biggest newspapers hacked
discus
which is this commenting system people
use on-based websites
to to docs anonymous commenters
go to their homes and film them knock on
the door when they come out there's a
camera in their face why'd you say this
disparaging comment about you know
immigrants or whatever
some of the comments were innocuous
saying i think sweden needs to take care
of their their
citizens and stop allocating tax funds
towards people who don't live here and
they're like why are you racist
these people got ambushed the question
is why was a newspaper hacking
and doxxing people and targeting
individuals
news organizations are supposed to be an
uh the necessary component of a
of a true democratic government or true
government of the people
they challenge the powers that be they
write the things that people don't want
to hear
instead they write the thing that the
tribalists love to hear as they burn the
witch
it's a wish hunts they go after people
for nasty opinions and they say this
woman she walked on the capitol
now we're seeing like anybody who's even
in dc is being targeted
were you in dc while it was going down
you're done they'll nuke you they'll ban
you they'll fire you'll come after you
there was that that one rapper guy who
got dropped from his label simply for
listening to trump speaking and leaving
there's that one army psychological
operations officer who went down in a
bus with some people saw trump speak and
then left and they are getting they're
getting investigated
there it's it's going to get bad man
i'll tell you so i have
a couple of things i want to throw out a
question make comment we'll come back to
the question maybe
do you think that they're going to under
prosecute those crimes
the ones that the capital i think it's
going to be
that they are going i think they're
going to look in the book and try and
take
every possible technicality to make it
sound worse than it is and give them
the highest maximum everything maximum
penalty yeah that's that's
the prosecution but essentially it's
still going to appeal to the judge well
i'll clarify my earlier point of
misdemeanors
a normal person who receives misdemeanor
because a slab on the wrist in court
supervision
this i do believe will be different
because i mean some misdemeanors are
punishable by like a thousand dollars in
a year in jail
right yeah yeah uh anything more than a
year i think becomes felony yeah you
know so so
she she could get up to a year i don't
uh i think she might
and i think you know all what did she do
if you walked past the barrier they're
charging you with a crime for being at
the capitol
that's it yeah two crimes essentially so
she could
i don't know i don't think she should
she could get more than year off
misdemeanors but
i think in this case while these you
know if you told me that someone was
facing a misdemeanor charge
and they were given permission to go on
vacation they'd be like and yeah right
wait if someone's
on the capitol property while it was
being broken into they're getting
charged not while i was even
being broken into they set up barriers
and if you walk past the barrier you get
charged
because the barriers were set up right
it was restricted so what's interesting
about the media turning its attention
away from the establishment and public
figures towards
individual citizens this is portending
portending i think that's the word
predicting the future of our own
apparatus the other big apparatus the
government
turning its attention onto the civilians
instead of on the citizens instead of on
the big things that matter
what is it what is it about our time
that's make the individuals so
dangerous that they have to be squashed
by the media controlled by the
government
corralled by a counter insurgency
program within the united states
they always are they are they feeling
are they feeling vulnerable
they've always had control of the plebs
since the beginning times there's always
been an aristocracy the greeks there's
always
been gods and men basically and uh it's
it's sad to say you know when you had
this
uh this this government in the in in
london
the king and all that stuff in
parliament but the colonies were
thousands of miles away the influence
was strained to the point where it
snapped
yeah and they could have listened to the
grievances
of the colonists and it probably would
have averted the revolution
but look at the declaration of
independence they literally say here are
all the things we have tried
petitioning and won't be resolved
they're not listening to us so then they
declare independence
all of a sudden the rabble snapped off
the control from the aristocracy and the
lords
but you know but let me just mention do
you guys know that the house of lords in
the uk literally is just
landed gentry and like religious
high-ranking individuals
they literally imagine if our senate was
comprised of
just uh you know super wealthy
millionaires who are politically
you know had political access and were
just essentially
you know uh using corporate money and
influence
and connections to get these political
positions as it gets man wait well
it's not that you're saying now no the
point i'm making is when you look at the
uk and you can see they have a house of
lords
literally the lords who are making the
laws and then you look at the united
states
we just call it by a different name and
pretend it's not yeah but it is yeah and
like when the founding fathers snapped
off the rabble and made the u.s then
they just broke up the rabble into the
gods of the rabble and the men
it's the initial uh the initial strategy
uh constitutional plan for senators was
that the state legislatures
would appoint their senators to the
federal senate
that way they literally said better men
would be the ones
having these conversations i think about
this a lot because humans are animals
i've
talked about this consistently and and
you know uneducated people are
essentially wild animals if you're born
in the woods and you don't aren't
socialized properly you're going to act
like a wolf
and so what are we supposed to herd the
the sheep and and have like a group of
of shepherds that
lead and control things and is that yes
and people are vying to become one of
the shepherds
look hierarchies exist all over nature
and for
lobsters for a reason yeah jbp now yeah
yeah no but here's here's the issue the
answer is yes the problem is
meritocracy is the right way people who
have earned the respect and earned the
right and genuinely care for the flock
the problem now is we don't have sheep
dogs and sheep
we have wolves pretending to be the
sheepdogs
and then mutilating the sheep so people
that are born into money
not necessarily no i mean aoc wasn't
necessarily born into money i mean
relative to the world she was and i
think to a certain degree she was like
middle class so
she wasn't poor by any stretch of the
imagination but look what she does to
empower herself
at the expense of others the capital
rights are all about her now and she'll
make up this crazy story
and embellish and exaggerate to gain
power i don't even think she was always
like that
i think that power can corrupt you and
make you selfish
i mean we don't know her you didn't you
didn't know her back then you didn't see
what she was saying back then so we just
don't know
we just see her for what she does now it
feels like the system to me that we
that to me the system that we have today
specifically selects for people
who are selfish inward thinking
manipulative control freaks
it does not select for genuine but
generous kind outward loving people so
the issue is
this is interesting in the old um
lordships at least i guess you had a
chance of having a certain amount of the
lords
actually care about being true statesmen
and helping their countrymen
and being a good person the problem is
with the system we've created of
election by popular vote it seems much
more likely that the people who will get
there are the sociopaths who will claw
their way to the top
whereas if you appoint people by random
you'd have more like you'd more likely
get
you know altruistic individuals i don't
think so because when you would have
landlords
and they would pass oh they'd have a
child and the child would just be a
groveling idiot they'd get the entire
land and then they'd become the
controller but
the landlord's knight the great noble
knight who raised their child to be this
phenomenal human would be a commoner to
and serve this
idiot mathematical son mathematically if
to become a lord you must manipulate lie
cheat and steal to gain political
prominence and
and to gain attention it is more likely
that a good honorable noble citizen will
not do
what needs to be done to win that office
however
if you have a whole bunch of lords a
bunch of them are probably going to be
the worst of the worst but you might at
least get one or two
where they're like i'm going to do my
best for my people now i'm not an
advocate of that system i'm just
pointing out
how kind of hilarious it is that we've
tried to build this system that would be
better for buy and of the people
and essentially now a couple hundred
years later it is just maybe it's just
terrible
maybe we just need term limits but i i
always know that's not the problem
i always enjoy this discussion where
we're like what if we just took somebody
by
lottery and put them in charge we would
do better denmark
let's think about this for a second
though random
people who win the lottery
what is our general sense of how they
handle that newfound sense of wealth and
power they blow it they usually screw it
up
that's that's how it used to be uh since
you have the stats
i've read i read a bit about it actually
yeah so so uh you know in the late 90s
there were a lot of shows that came out
talking about people who blew their
lottery winnings
and how mo money mo problems and their
family started hating them and then the
money ran out they didn't know what to
do with it they didn't even know where
to put it
well once those stories started coming
out people in the past couple of decades
have consulted wealth management firms
and have done a very good job of
managing the new lottery winnings
yeah and there was one story i read
where a guy won like a hundred something
a million dollars or so
or something like that maybe it was like
70. and then he set aside how much he
needed
based on wealth management advice to put
away to be retired and be wealthy for
the rest of his life
and then started writing checks to
people who asked people would send him
letters saying any money for this and
he'd be like
the internet it has been kind of a great
equalizer it comes to education and
controlling money is a is an acquired
ability so that's kind of nice but the
the idea of demarchy isn't that we would
create a government of
only randomly chosen people it's that
you would have multiple
layers much like we do now with the
senate with with the representatives
and then maybe what we need is a fourth
branch which would be the demarcate
yes the national initiative have you
guys studied this mike gravel was trying
to push this through in like 2004 it
would create a fourth branch of
government that would allow
every state to add a representative to
this this
national initiative branch of government
that would be people just common people
that
could then pass right and pass lawyers
it would have to be denmark
it would have to be that one day you
walk to your mailbox and you're like i
got choked like jury duty
exactly and it would be for like a month
and then they would set you up it would
be
you'd be accommodated you'd be
compensated and there would have to be
protections where you can't get fired
from your job
if you were selected for i would love to
start pushing something like this
because the national initiative is not
going to get passed by congress
according to microvel and it would be
something that the citizens would have
to pass 51
of us would have to come together and
make this happen by what is that called
when you get people just to
do something by decree basically the
mass majority it's not it's not it's not
a grand solution though
a bunch of you know if you take a random
person they're gonna
if we brought a random person right now
the way it's built is i'm talking about
demarcus what we were talking about
if you brought a random person out and
asked them about any of this they would
want a random person well so i don't
know what you're talking about we were
literally like
we're talking about the conversation
before tonight it's called the national
initiative
you're not having the same conversation
as we are you're talking about putting
random people in charge it's insane
ian please please okay tell me how it's
great
jack murphy brought up demarchy and then
you brought up a fourth branch of
government
a democratic branch of government in
response to what jack murphy
i don't think random people is the right
way to do it so that's that's the
conversation
i don't know if jack you wanted to
you're making a comment about del mar
key yeah you know it's interesting
we trust a jury of 12 to decide
life or death on a random basis well we
don't trust a judge you may be a random
guy
you make the case you got to go to
school to be a judge you got to which is
why there's multiple things
yeah you have a group of juries that
basically and the judge can overturn the
jury no they can't
they can overturn the jury or they can
give instructions so yes they can
no you just said no they can't they can
i was actually saying a sentence ian or
they can
give instructions yeah i said they can
overrule the jury or give instructions
in certain
circumstances but you jumped in before i
finished the sentence what's the
circumstance that they couldn't if the
jury comes out
and says we find the defendant not
guilty the judge says well so be it it
was a jury trial he doesn't then go no i
reject now there are certain
circumstances where judges have actually
done this
and it results in crazy constitutional
crises and lawsuits
where judges have been like i don't care
what the jury said lock them up contempt
of court
yeah legally they're allowed to do that
they're not that's what they're supposed
to do they're supposed to keep the
jury in check basically by giving
instructions like disregard that that's
against the rules
not by i'm shutting the jury down
because they ruled in a way i don't like
they're not it's it's very dictatorial
to do the idea is
what if instead of you know when people
run for congress they need a ton of
money
it's very difficult they need popularity
aoc manages this by being bombastic and
being a sensational character
she raises millions of dollars across
the nation and to be completely honest
there are a lot of politicians who raise
money outside of this country which is
illegal and they do it through
nonprofits and circuits means
but aoc is not doing that i'm not saying
she does but she raises money all over
the country for her one district
because she's prominent that makes it
impossible for someone to run against
her because of her profile
so you have the senate which is mostly
millionaires
i'm pretty sure they're all millionaires
i think they all are not actually no i
think there's a few that make like
that are worth like half a million
dollars but it's very difficult to win a
state to be a senator
to work to run in congress it's not as
hard because you're in a smaller area
it's easier to go around and talk to
people but you still need a ton of money
so the idea of demarchy just as you know
jack was bringing up not as a
necessarily good thing because you were
critical of it and people how they spend
their money in the lottery
would be the idea that we would try and
take random regular people
without the restrictions of not having
enough money or not being a political
insider
and giving them a chance to sit down go
over these bills for a short period of
time
and then weigh in on it regular people
not special political elites who are
allowed to bear arms when we are not
not people who have connections to big
industry or massive twitter pro
profiles where they can fundraise off of
a regular guy who is is you know he's a
tradesman of some sort or a woman who's
a homemaker for that for that matter or
a
woman finally now going to the table and
and you know once in a while having kind
of jury duty-like system but like
like truly random like anyone could be
within like a certain age range older
than 18 it would be like jury duty
like some like a bunch of mentally
unstable people though
yeah that don't want to be there are
they human beings yeah do they have
rights
yeah can they vote yeah well there you
go but i don't think i want them passing
laws
it wouldn't be like 10 people it would
be like 500 or so
so ian you've already begun to
re-establish the hierarchy yeah
some people i mean i'm honest iq is a
thing
and there's we measure that kind of
ability to calculate and to think
hierarchies are good but the only way
they work is if it works for everyone
involved in the hierarchy that's why
when you lead you have to be a servant
you have to be a servant leader you have
to be how can i
help the people that i'm leading how can
i help the people that are following me
and i take the same approach on my
twitter profile on my twitter page
i'm like guys get out of washington dc
nothing bad is going to happen right now
please stay and please stay in the
suburbs don't come to the city don't do
this
i'm trying to help people maybe denmark
is the way to go it's
temporary just another branch it's like
you get a month it's like a jury dude or
maybe even a couple weeks
and what happens is you have a thousand
maybe even 3 000 people
are randomly chosen once a month and
then their travel is paid for
they come to a you know this big you
know auditorium-like room
where they're given a packet of
information to read through and then
cast their votes on certain issues
and it's just another layer that
provides
regular people the chance to come and
have their voice heard and then
their vote votes were all public and
they go back you know a month later and
people who live near them know what they
voted for
and they say you voted to take my money
with that tax increase are you nuts
and so then people are concerned am i
going to defy the will of my neighbors
by voting for the special interests no
way i'm only here for a month
it's and and maybe not even a month
maybe it's like for specific votes i
don't
exactly know if it's a good idea or i'm
saying i'm not saying it will work i'm
saying it's an interesting there's
something good about term limits that's
for sure
because you know you're not there to win
people's favor and stay in office you're
just there to do the job
it's there's still a lot of arguments
for against term limits it's you know i
think this the the problems we face
are not so easily solved and it's
interesting
you know i was in this conversation the
other day i remember what movie we were
watching
it was about something about air
conditioning and i was just like isn't
it crazy that
like there's a lot of people who have a
general concept of how air conditioning
works
and if they went back hundreds of years
they could describe it to someone and
probably make some kind of rudimentary
air conditioner of some sort maybe not
hundreds of years you'd still need some
kind of like electricity or some kind of
you know pressurization system but as
just a layman right now
as some random person you can be like i
know how to make a bow and arrow under
the general concept
whereas at a certain point it took like
some genius guy
hard work and 10 years to be like i
finally figured out how to make a
compound bow
but now we just take all this
information for granted we just know
these things
so anyway i digress it's just i find it
fascinating
that we actually know so much about so
many different things
and then i don't know if the solution is
going to be demarchy it's just an
interesting concept we're bringing up
what i'm trying to say is the solution
may be simple in 100 years but right now
we are
fighting as hard as possible to figure
out what that methodology or technology
will be
is the united states government in a
necessarily uh
more precarious or nefarious or
dangerous circumstance than it has been
at any other time in its history
i think the answer is yes this is the
most critical
crucial uh i'd say the most oh that was
that was that was
that was my question or like is this
just the natural
state of our republic that's what i'm
really getting at i think
as we've heard from many scholars there
has not been a tumultuous time like this
save the civil war yeah world war one
was pretty rough i think
well we heard it was putin i think said
what the world is going through right
now is much like
pre-world war ii yeah he said that a few
days ago and we have to understand on
the historical context having things
like the first amendment
the second amendment they are extremely
rare circumstances where people are able
to have these amazing god-giving
rights that usually typically all
throughout history are
usually taken away from them because of
big government so the the fact that
these
important freedoms are under threat
right now is something that should be
concerning everyone
i think it's also interesting to
consider the context uh
the context that our government is in
that we're all in
in 2021 i mean it's novel every year
because things always change
but this is radically different with the
technology social media communications
the
the
complete just flattening of the globe
etc
uh this is a novel laboratory in which
to test
the republic i'm feeling desperate like
i snapped to anger
10 minutes ago because i'm feeling this
is like freaking me out
this is like people are getting arrested
it's not
it it's not a joke you know this is if
it's really like pre-world world war ii
that's terrifying man we're the
organizers look people i i think this is
actually funny but
people are comparing january 6 to the
burning of the reichstag
like this is their this is their pretext
for the enabling act and this is what it
was it was it wasn't the enabling act
though was it was it bringing the right
side with the enabling
hitler the burning the so the reichstag
burned down the capital the german
parliament and then hitler blamed
it on the communists and then they he
used that as is like pretext to declare
the enabling act take everyone's weapons
disarm the population
i i had a tweet earlier today on this
subject
um what where's the best place for a
forever war but at home
it's easy it's here it's right here i'm
saying forever war
in america we love forever wars oh right
the best place for a forever war
is right here at home you don't have to
travel you don't send people abroad
you got the addresses the social
security numbers of everybody that you
want to prosecute and terrorize
forever war at home and especially if
it's combined with the long
night of tyranny from the corporate
techno fascism that we are now under
if they get the ai and they get
everything that they want it could be a
switch yeah it's flipped that cannot be
unturned well on that note very positive
smash button
subscribe to the notification bell smash
that like button we're going to take
your super chats but my friends just
wait we are going to have a bonus
segment an exclusive members only
segment of the show that appears on
timcast.com
for those who are paying members this is
our way of offering up two different
kinds of the same business
you get your free content here you can
super chat if you'd like we'll read your
super chats or you can watch the youtube
videos for free
and then we have the stuff that if
you're a paying member you get ad free
just exclusive member only
content and it's like what did jack just
talk about technofascism
yeah i'd like to at least have some kind
of backup plan
and you guys who are members are
essentially our shield our safety net in
the event we get banned on
you know whatever podcast platform or
youtube we'll have that
forever for however long that lasts
until they start pulling web services
and stuff like that so
that being said i've been down on
timcast.com and i got to say it's a good
website nice and easy so
there's a lot of great content on there
there's going to be us on there cussing
up the storm and just to close
up a storm wonderful because man holding
it in this whole time
it's very it's been very hard it's
turning red it's been very hard you saw
me i was like they've just
he almost said it yeah i almost said it
let's read some of these super chats all
right we got uh i'm not your buddy guy
says not really important or related but
i just got into this show called the
expanse on amazon prime you gotta check
it out i tried dude
everybody says it's amazing i tried the
first two episodes and i was just like
this
is boring as pink really i thought it
was great what's the scenario i i
just i'm not big on tv shows as it is
did you did you go through this i
watched like i think like the first
season i think
man maybe and then i get a shot i don't
know like i watched half of the
mandalorian and i was enjoying it but i
just don't watch tv oh dude mandalorian
got
real good second season the second half
of the second season
was like sensational goosebumps
changed my whole like childhood arc in
my mind
i don't want to give too much away but
they they did write a new star wars
chapter at the end of that
with some very important characters if
you want to watch it i think they've
just beaten star wars like a
dead horse just like just beating it
over and over again i agree but
i think mandalorian is very very well
done and it's the same guy that
uh you know the uh avengers stuff yeah
yeah yeah you know i liked it i liked
the first season yeah
the expanse of that was cool it's like
basically you know what it's about ian
no they like humans have colonized mars
and the asteroid belt
and you know i think the moons of like
jupiter saturn or something and so the
people who live in
the belt are all like really tall and
lanky and like frail because there's no
gravity
and then mars like broke away and became
their own government they declared
independence and now it's a very
militarized
society because it was the military
colony that declared independence so
it's like yeah i thought it was a cool
show
you know a show that i i everybody else
would love that i tried that i
absolutely hated cobra kai
why did people tell me that this was
going to be a good show you didn't like
cobra
oh my god the first one that was so bad
well i thought it was i thought it was
fine
i'm not going to pretend like it was the
greatest it's meant to be campy yeah
it's meant to be super campy it's it's
mocking karate kid
it's supposed to be like silly it's
mocking its
own origin story yes do you know how
this move the show came to be
no but i mean there was the same
character there was a very same there
was a viral meme
explaining how the karate kid was the
bad guy it was like this viral video or
something where they were like
think about it and it was someone
justifying how the bad guy was actually
the good guy like you're somebody who's
been training your whole life
and like this kid comes in as an illegal
kick and then they incorporated that
actually as the pretext for the show
cobra kai yeah and i thought it was fun
i haven't watched second season or
anything like that but like we gotta
read more super chats i'm just talking
about our tv shows that we like
oh i thought let's see uh yuki's
questions
hello tim and cass i love your show but
i'm going to shamelessly plug my game
that's on steam
defend your buttress also my patreon
ugj031
says f in the chat for the boys who
missed the garillionaire train buying
stunks
stay awesome irl crew i'm not entirely
sure the whole thing's over
we'll see see cody emin says did you all
see tucker carlson was on dancing with
the stars
to appreciate all of your work for
everyone wait he was
he was i didn't see that come on i don't
know about that move it
apache shepard says would you kindly
read this super chat
i felt compelled to do that for some
reason i don't understand persuasion no
do you know the references oh no
uh bioshock oh okay yeah the first game
you you you got to play biology yeah
you're a great
original yeah if it's like it's it's
it's they used ein rand
atlas shrugged as kind of like an
artistic pretext and like ideology
beautiful
beautiful but uh spoiler alert for this
like what 20 something year old game
whenever someone says to the main
character would you kindly he's
compelled to do it
yeah so it's like he's being manipulated
it's dude bioshock is awesome
and then bioshock 2 is okay bioshock
infinite is pretty good but bioshock 1
is
awesome bioshock is great good game now
we're talking about video games and tv
shows
great all right let's see we got here
petty says reminder that cuomo killed
more people than 911
that the first shots fired at fort
sumter were fired by a tax ship
also biden's amnesty plan is tantamount
to slavery
yeah what's what's his amnesty plan i
got to read into it student of history
says happy to
know that uh happy to happy to know that
now
they're agreeing with hitler's opinion
that slavs aren't white
now i'm waiting for the answers on the
mediterranean race spanish and italians
clarifying this is a joke a good lord
well we now have uh uh you know for for
a while this show was
was was led by a minority but then i
found out that asian people were white
so i'm actually double white which makes
me more white than
both jack and and ian and lydia but now
that luke's a person of color
uh we're good we're good we have
diversity back in the show you know this
is a serious question actually i
have a chapter in my book called what is
white anyway in democrat and deplorable
what is white anyway that's a real
question
and when did everybody become all white
and why well so this is actually one of
the progressives talking points that
white wasn't always italian and it's not
right right and
and then it changes and so that's why
they say whiteness isn't about the color
of your skin
it's about a social construct of the the
majority
controlling or oppressive class that's
how they kind of deviated or whatever
yeah whatever sounds legit all right
jay says just got to ask are you guys
going to talk about the real controversy
like the farmer revolt going on in india
right now
i've been looking into it i just don't
know enough about what's going on with
with india i know that they're going to
they want to ban cryptocurrency too but
there's like a farmer revolt so like
some big news yeah some things i just if
i don't know enough about we don't get
into
block 47 says i've heard several
different explanations of what q anon is
every source seems to have their own
take and i can't seem to make full sense
of it
what is q anon and what do they believe
what q anon believes is not a thing you
can pin down or who
or what it is either it seems like it
was co-opted like it's so maybe someone
in intelligence started it off and
started with
4chan was it 8-channel or 4chan post was
8-chan i think it was 8-chan posts where
someone's saying cue and then asking
these questions
and then the narrative emerged this
individual had q clearance which my
understanding is not a real thing but it
was supposed to be like high level
clearance and they were
secretly working with trump to go after
hillary i i didn't know too much about
it for a long time and i kind of just
disregarded it because it was like kind
of fringe
but then once it started to become more
prominent with the media and asking
trump
you know i looked up more about it and
started reading more about it and it's
just
it's just on it's ridiculous i i've got
some people who keep saying over and
over again that like
tomorrow's the day trump's gonna pull it
off tomorrow's the day and i'm like dude
trump's not the president
he's gone trust the plan and and now
they're saying march is the real
inauguration date because
america was incorporated and it's like
did you read the history of how they
changed the date of inauguration and all
this stuff it's like
dude q anon is squarely anti-trump
squarely anti-maga it siphoned off
positive maga energy into a destructive
downward spiral that led to january 6th
and now will usher in
the tyranny of the 21st century so thank
you q anon
there we go thanks a lot mark hicks says
a shout out to for congressman devin
nunes
he exposed the russia hoax and the
criminals responsible
those responsible have been punished
with one instance of probation for
falsifying documents submitted to the
fisa court
there you go count ludwig says i am
looking to invest in crypto but have
limited understanding of them
what's the favorite cryptocurrency of
tim and all his co-hosts and guests who
are invested in cryptos and why
i cannot give you financial advice and i
am uh i'm a [ __ ] don't listen to me
that being said
i was told by bill ottman of of mines
friends
good friend of van they co-founded mine
together who was on the show and he said
ethereum i think he said it on the show
i know he did ethereum was undervalued
and i said i'm gonna buy some then i
bought aetherium
and now it's at sixteen hundred dollars
all-time high
so at the time when bill's had to buy it
was at a thousand and that's at an
all-time high it may have gone down a
little bit let me tell you something
bitcoin is a store of value first
in best dressed that's how we explained
bitcoin
it was the first crypto it was the most
it is and it
is it is and now has always been the
most prominent crypto
so it has been the go-to choice for
people who wanted to hold a digital
asset that cannot be copied
however what can bitcoin really do it
does have some technology behind it it
can execute some kind of smart
smart contracts but it's fairly
rudimentary ethereum in my opinion
should be worth more than bitcoin you
know why
we'll use mines for example mines offers
tokens the tokens are er
creditor erc 20 tokens right so that
means they're basically tokens that
exist within
ethereum well within the ethereum
blockchain yes the ethereum blockchain
is different than the ethereum token
and the ethereum token exists on an
erc20 blockchain
so the the general idea is ethereum
actually is a component of many
businesses
many many businesses and it is required
for them to continue function
functioning uh if they if they're using
the ethereum blockchain
bitcoin isn't being used by businesses
except for a store of value and that's
because it's actually cheaper to trade
ethereum than to trade bitcoin that's a
big part of it
so i'll tell you this i think ethereum's
going to eventually be worth way way
more yeah it was um
when in the early days when bitcoin was
20 000 i think ethereum was like 12.
so if you look at that ratio now you're
looking at bitcoin at 37 it's almost
double
ethereum has not doubled 12 yet and it
probably maybe maybe one way to look at
it is that
uh bitcoin is gold they say it's digital
gold right so you can hold it and it's
very valuable and it will continue to be
valuable and probably will always be
particularly valuable but ethereum is
more like a material that you need for
your for your business maybe like
copper wiring or something it's a it's a
metal
and you forged you need it to actually
run your business so people start buying
way more ethereum and using ethereum way
more because it's a
it's a it's an infrastructure asset for
your company what do you i kind of i
agree with you ethereum's my top one
right now i also like polka dot it's not
um
right now it's not considered uh
security so it's not traded in the
united states but it allows
interoperability between blockchains so
it will allow for that
rc yeah it's huge yeah and it's like the
fourth most valuable one right now in
the world
yeah uh what do you guys think about
where you guys at uh not financial
advice i'm really really stupid
uh but i see a lot of promise and a lot
of talk about monero
and its capabilities that a lot of
people are flocking to
so because it says it doesn't publicly
track what you would you trade
yeah uh yeah well let's move on lydia i
love bitcoin by the way
did you have something to say jack no i
really don't i can't add to this
conversation at all i started buying
bitcoin first in 2011.
lucky i don't know anything else about
it there you go
biwe says what's up from oklahoma the
truth tastes good thank you guys for
what you do
well we try all right azazel the fallen
says aoc is a sociopath in the same vein
as hillary
remember her story about sniper fire i'm
not being facetious she is literally a
sociopath
i mean i think i said the same thing so
yeah mr hunt
first name michael says we are in an
information war they lie cheat and steal
we must fight back the truth matters
and if it's an information war then you
win by bringing out good information
control your personal narrative correct
vince stark says aoc is the inverse of
trump she has a fan base
she has a populist agenda and she uses
social media to fire her base aoc is not
based she's a leftist populist chill
interesting sir patrick the great says
you guys gather the best
i used to be way far right but as i got
older i realized who cares
but for real i'm libertarian with a
right pole you all stay safe and much
love from texas
appreciate it dan lamarr says you wonder
why the cop might have been pissed
he got sent there to collect her because
she wasn't doing the protocol
answering text calls and i'll bet the
staff played games with him at the door
there it is is that confirmed does that
work she mentioned that she didn't go to
the extraction point because she was
scared of the other congress people
so then they call this guy that's why he
was angry yup aoc is not following
protocol
she's not going to the extraction
location can you go and get her and then
he's like there's a riot going on
people are freaking out and she's not
following pro come on lady
let's go i'm going to get in trouble
seriously you're going to get us killed
yeah dude i have been oh man do you want
you want to know what anger feels like
i've done
not only have i done hostile environment
training okay i think it was silly
because i grew up on the south side of
chicago i don't need training for that i
lived it
but i have been in say ferguson's good
example
i'm in ferguson gunshots ring out i hit
the deck
i look to my right my filmer producer
who's with me hits the ground before i
looked at my he's already on the ground
i'm like good good man look to my left
and there's this journalist
for one company going looking around
just lose fireworks
and i'm like oh dude well look you know
what i wasn't working with a guy so i'm
not really all that frustrated but i am
just kind of like dude
are you insane you have no idea what
you're doing you are going to get
yourself killed
and there was another moment where i was
in a particular situation
and someone i was working with and
gunshots rang out and i hit the deck
along with literally everyone else
around us
but this one person that was sent to
work with me was standing around camera
uh you know filming just being like it's
fireworks
and i'm like okay now you're going to
get me killed so i can understand why
that cop was probably mad
i'm going to have to now risk my neck
running into this building because she
wouldn't get out when she was told to
and then she changed the story why
wouldn't the cop tell us okay
sure i'm sure she has a reputation too
yup yup she hates cops she rags on them
she supports the riots and he's like i
gotta go
this is nuts west
uh let's see west side powersports
seadoo part says hey tim the videos
behind the paywall are pure gold
the way you use your f-bombs is so
poetic i peed myself a little when ian
was talking about his current dating
situation absolutely epic
dude apparently some ladies dating
during kovitz
that's the brief yeah uh for those that
aren't familiar if you go to timcast.com
and check out our members only content
ian basically broke down and was like
covet has made it impossible to date
yes and then luke was like are there any
ladies out there luke scott
i'm literally cupid he's been keeping
tabs we're working the system
all right worm says take the stimulus
cash and stay gold gang we the people
will jettison you a
into a billion dollar empire to join the
ranks of elon musk and based
individualist
bad a's of the people more power to you
yeah i think that's true i
and i want to really decentralize the
internet i think that's kind of the
direction we're heading it's pretty
exciting
did we talk about oh we didn't talk
about this live so i'll keep it
relatively vague the general idea
that i had was to instead of trying to
create a new social network
that's like some kind of patreon system
it's about creating a white label
software that anyone i think i talked
about this in the show last week or
something a white label software that's
open source
that anybody could just install on their
server and then drag and drop some logos
and then have their own version of
patreon that they control with their own
merchant account
people sign up but they could the these
these this software can connect and
network to anyone else using the
software
so if someone says i demand that you ban
this person hey man they're running
their own server in their own node
i can't control that but it does connect
with my node so people can cross comment
yeah there's a program called riot which
is uh use the matrix protocol and it
looks like that might be the future of
decentralized messaging it's kind of
like discord but an open source version
of it
imagine like patreon though with
subscribers
free and paid and then if like you go to
like ian's
you know ian's world whatever and then
you're like watching ian talk about you
know dmt and time and whatever
you can also click the community tab and
it'll show you the community of all of
the
the noted networks that are popping up
we're also individually controlled not
by any has no control over them building
an ai that can like
watch video and tell you like like you
take a picture of this gorilla and then
it'll search all the videos on the
network and find
like what is this gorilla i'll tell you
about it like kind of like a wiki but
through video
all right let's see we got let's do
another super chat pops vindaloo says
luke thinking about starting the rv life
any suggestions on where to look for an
affordable rv
um usually different marketplaces
i i really really don't like facebook
but they have a marketplace
uh craigslist is also really good being
able to
do research on your rv what you
specifically need is crucially important
there's a lot of lemons out there
there's a lot of water damage out there
you got to be careful of and it really
took me
a long time to make sure i got something
good i got a good deal on it
and a lot of the dealerships you know a
lot of the big ones they're just like
car dealerships so you know what you're
getting yourself into
when you're dealing with car dealerships
but uh just keep an eye out look at
market places look at individual sales
those usually are the best ones
greg mccormick says tim rashid tula only
opposed spending bill because money was
being sent to israel
she has she has been consistently
anti-semitic this this wasn't a
coincidence
peace loved the show well i hear you i
do um
it's an issue of aoc's support for the
corporate establishment machine just
blindly voting for pelosi blindly
supporting these bills
and i can absolutely disagree with
rashida to labe but that's the point i
was making i
really do disagree with her basically
everything but i
i the way i framed it was i think aoc is
lying and i think richard clay
genuinely believes the thing she's
saying and that's the difference so
not someone i would vote for but i
understand like i i think she's actually
believes this stuff
i don't think aoc believes what she's
saying she when she first got elected
she changed her opinions on a bunch of
things i got criticized for the left for
it
you can respect authenticity exactly
even if you don't agree
even if you think it's wrong and bad
yeah i like authentic
all right gabriel gabriel nestor says
tim i'm a history teacher in california
needless to say i'm looking for
different things i'm 29. you inspired me
to make a mini youtube documentary on
hyperbole in the media
super excited to release cool glad to
hear it congratulations good luck with
that dude
united we stan says please contact your
house rep about hr127
stand up for our rights right to bear
arms right to privacy join tim's website
that last one was really great yeah but
hr 127 is is insane
i don't think it'll pass are you
familiar with this i am not it basically
says you can't buy a gun unless you're
21
you got to get liability insurance you
got to get licensed by the attorney
general
it's like a whole bunch of crazy
mandatory psych evaluations banning 50
bmgs
every every gun is registered and taxed
so it's like
it's hardcore but it's unconstitutional
in a very obvious way the problem is
keep and bear arms shall not be
infringed yet many places have already
violated that and there's no
there's no no one's gonna like nothing
to be done about it so
don't underestimate it make sure you
speak out against these things
you know i think it's it's a pretty
extreme bill
javi j says question i am a slovak
jewish
japanese mexican does that make me
neutral on the oppression scale i am so
confused
no no you're super oppressed the asian
kind of negates it a little bit but you
know you're you're more oppressed than
you are in a presence
asian makes you more white though so i i
think you're still technically white and
you know where the word
slav comes from slave yeah
they were the slaves yeah is that it i
think it's
where the word slave comes from i
thought it was the other way around yeah
that's the other way around
like slave comes from the word slovakia
from the word slav
you're not a slave luke you're a free
man how dare you
how dare you insult my people oh that
was a double negative what have i done
all right here we go kristoff westrom
says keep it the great work tim ian be
my shaman i want to try dmt
i am a gorilla yankee in the holler on
youtube just started don't judge me yet
harumph very cool
i will say i saw the prototype of the
new shirt coming out i posted an image
on on um
instagram but that is not the image on
the shirt and i'll send it to you
it's a yeah someone else that's very
cool our designer was like
ian doesn't like my design no i love her
design yeah
it's very cool it says free the code
i'm gonna get one immediately yeah okay
uh kt
rouge says please try to get dave
chappelle please
yes i will uh i'll go outside as soon as
the show shows over and wait
for a shooting star to wish that dave
chappelle i love that
dave and joe and elon are all friends
hanging out in austin
i don't know i think dave lives in
austin rogan joe rogan and elon musk
yeah i'm talking about and um there's
like pictures of the comedy club hanging
out
now that they're all friends now they're
doing a tour are they doing
they were doing shows together chappelle
yeah yeah yeah
uh dave is uh i think it's fair to say
the greatest comedian of our generation
100
from from my hometown from my
neighborhood went to high school with
people that i know he came up in the dc
comedy clubs like he's a dc product he's
he's smart funny hysterical an amazing
storyteller
he makes the craft look effortless i
love that guy
and i really loved the netflix special
because he did a whole bunch of really
offensive things he did the the like the
old school
offensive chinese stereotype thing and
uh
it was it it was like
it was bold it was meant to trigger it
was he was he was literally
trying to trigger like people's like you
know pc sensibilities
and i respect him for doing it and i'm
part asian i thought it was fantastic
he makes the rounds though he doesn't
just stop on one and if you get
everybody then it's okay like south park
his bid on the kung flu
was really yeah that was good
trump's not supposed to be funny he's
not supposed to do that
oh no it's offensive am i allowed to say
these things because i'm part asian
there was a funny video it's from
college humor and there's a panel of
full asian half asian and quarter asian
judging people who are part asian on
what they're allowed to do or not do
and it was really really funny so it's
like you know this guy comes up and he's
like i'm one eighth asian
am i allowed to use chopsticks to eat my
food and then they're like the panel
discusses
it's a really it's you gotta watch it
it's funny then there's like at the end
a guy walks in who's like
white and he goes my great great
grandfather was black and all the
judges go you're black so i was like but
it was college humor it was really funny
because it is a funny take on
you know the pc politics of like when
you're part asian what constitutes
actually having the right to make
offensive jokes or whatever
tim i'll allow it okay okay cool but
we're not the same race so you're not
allowed to make fun of me no no no no
but but i'm uh you know a person of
color
yeah you're you're not you're like right
now same so no joke
what the heck just happened what the
heck you know what
interestingly though it is a good point
are you mad no no that my
are finally getting justice from all the
horrible servitude
all the horrible barriers that are in
front of the polish people the nazis the
communists don't make me go after about
the plight
of the polish people and then we have to
go here
and you're mad that we're finally
getting our reparations no no i'm happy
let me tell you a story i have a
ukrainian friend and
uh she was telling me that's really
really difficult to come to the united
states
and she's a feminist leftist in ukraine
and so i try explaining to her what's
going on with critical race theory in
american culture and feminism and she's
confused she says like
you know i i have friends who say that
you're far right and i was like you've
known me for
how many years is that true and she goes
no it makes no sense and i was like let
me explain to you like american feminism
and so when we start talking about you
know she wants to come to the united
states but it's very difficult
i said well have you tried explaining to
them that you are white
and she she laughed and said my white
privilege ends the cover of my passport
ukraine you're not you don't have
privilege so so
is is ukrainian slavic it is yeah yeah
so
it's an interesting point like i always
bring up to people when i'm like if you
think there's white privilege
let me let me let me pay for your flight
to the ukraine you know or i shouldn't
say the uk it's just ukraine now
let me pay for your flight and you can
go hang out there some of these people
make a hundred dollars a month like the
i think the average
income the general like the average
salary for middle like middle class
people is like 400 bucks a month
not privileged all right let's read uh
we got adam davidson saying tim on seth
rogen note check out his hilarious
interaction with the great gad sad
toasters there you go joey jk pitt says
your cab ride story reminds me of
multiple times with my job dealing with
customer service
i tell toe workers to kill him with
kindness yeah
an aniel reed says i love you ian i love
when you all talk metaphysics and the
occult yes yes yes
oh well thank you oh my god this is
awesome says ian is science
well here we go that's a little extreme
don't know if i'd go that far
wendy gusset says in a naked big in a
naked baked bean wrestling match between
ian and tim
who do who who do the team think would
win and why well what are the big
what are the what are the rules what are
the fights black beans are we talking
yeah yeah i have long fingernails
[Laughter]
tim doesn't have a pole i don't know
it could get dirty i can kick really
really well jim's fast he's like stabby
[Laughter]
all right do you want to read this one
that's uh
facetiously mean ian yeah you gave me
two good ones celeste john smith says
ian has the memory of an elephant and
the critical thinking skills of potato
i think elephants have a good memory
they have the best memory
yeah so that's why it was like
facetiously that's odd because i would
have flipped it around
i think i think that my skill my
thinking skills are better but my memory
sometimes
like a potato there you go
bn says i'm free spirited and can't be
tamed please legislate
my speech and control what ideas i'm
able to hear think and share
yeah boy you got it martin edgar says
trump is the new pluto
what does that mean huh oh the planet
that doesn't exist
oh yeah crystal brings a really good
point he says they did celebrate winning
on november 7th there was a mob
at the white house playing ymca to mock
trump's last rally and they were all
jumping in the street and swinging
champagne and stuff
but then after that it got really
mournful you know it's like a weird
now they're all angry and like what have
we done what have we done
the journalists were freaking out there
i don't know what they're gonna do
trumpism nice try
prad chucho says hey irl gang what's
what's y'all favorite donut
ooh glazed glazed that's the answer
i i i i would agree actually what do you
think little glazed jelly
jelly jelly i'm going glazed with the
chocolate icing
made some glazed kind of doughnut
doughnut oh that's right he had that
awesome glaze on him it was like a
cinnamon glaze
that was really good it was brown sugar
cinnamon vanilla a little bit of peanut
oil
some heavy cream and then we bake you
know we we cooked it oh we have a deep
fryer on the way yeah we have deep-fried
and then we made these these deep-fried
little discs they were like donuts
and then we just tossed them in this
glaze and uh people went nuts did you
get one of those home fryers about yay
big because
i got one of those yeah it's too small
after a while you just
you try doing wings you're doing like 35
batches i'm ready to get a commercial
size fire
i'm down it's full size just give me 50
wings at once
yes all right ravine payne says raven
payne sorry
so i really want to know is luke single
dibs
and amc plus gme diamond hands to the
moon
also need some sort of video where
everyone is high
as hell the whole time like ian is i
really want to see where things go
maybe the tables turn that'd be fun we
could either take acid or
dmt tim doesn't like when it's already
illegal
obviously no i'm saying i'm i don't do
drugs let's get started
and talk about whatever well i think
youtube will take that down
for sure yeah we'd have to put it on
private members the private thing no i'm
just kidding that phase of my life is
over
so richard cook says uk house of lords
has many political appointees not just
landed gentry
they are appointed by the government on
the day for life like scotus
interesting grant thompson says if
you're not bringing up hr127 you are
woefully not paying attention browse it
look for the punishment for not being
licensed if you are going to allow this
to happen then you ex
then accept then you accept your chains
yes
yep promise mcguffin says ian's wrong
all the time 60 of the time jk man your
good peeps might have to cancel you for
grabbing women though
luke's a great addition thank you i
never grabbed a woman
don't do it yeah what is that what was
that about well you made a statement
earlier
and i was like that's when you get
tasered advice for like young people
that are looking to get into
relationships and when you when you meet
someone
be willing to offer to shake their hand
i found that just making some sort of
physical contact when you first meet
someone really kind of breaks a barrier
and it makes it easier to get to know
them mind-blowing dude we should make
this accustom
i know it's crazy to think that we have
to continuously teach the young people
the things that we think are
common oh i say that's true yeah
especially with kobe it's why i thought
about doing porn
because i want to show people how to
have sex
you're going to teach people how to make
love yeah what better way
all right mikey says can you deep fry
with vinegar i know someone with 25
gallons of it
right
[Music]
wrestling or whatever it was music
dc uh music dc guy one says being how
ian has his view on everything his
energy
i would love to take him on a paranormal
investigation
that and we should bring tim too we we
talk and like watch those ghost shows
from time i kind of laugh about them
yeah it's so it's so obviously fake it's
like i love watching them though because
it's
funny it's funny and they know it's
funny but like a guy walks okay you've
been doing this for for 10 years
you've been to thousands of different
haunted houses and you're still
scared when someone goes oh what's that
what was that oh
i heard a noise oh dude and then they
all run out of the building and they're
like oh and they're filming themselves
freaking out but there's something we're
talking about the higgs field last night
and the god particle the higgs boson and
that there's this field where it seems
like energy is like cracking and turning
into matter so
you know if we can develop the right
sensors maybe we need to do more shows
actually so as we expand
timcast.com we're planning on actually
doing other sites as well
and i think we you know we talked about
this for a while i actually did a couple
episodes
cassandra wrote one episode for us it
was like a 10 or 50 minute long podcast
edited with music
and it was about the hauntings of of
disney of disney world i think
and like people see walt disney like
walking around and like appearing in a
window and creepy stuff like that
so we've done a couple of those and they
they were huge successes
you know so so we definitely want to do
weird wild paranormal conspiracy
and i think we've got to do new shows
for it and i'm totally down to do it
and uh i think it'll be coming soon
probably because i don't see why not
maybe like a weekend thing you know
we'll see
that being said i think uh we're gonna
move now to
the members only content so go to
timcast.com
and once we wrap up here we're going to
then record the segment so usually
around maybe like 11 it will be up
and it should be an interesting
discussion around i think we're talking
about critical race theory luke is now a
newly
defined person of color and there's some
stuff around this that we'll get into
so if you haven't go to timecast.com
sign up you can follow me on twitter
instagram and mines at tim cast my other
youtube channels are youtube.comcast
youtube.comcastnews and we do this show
monday through friday
live at 8 p.m we'll be back tomorrow of
course jack i hear that you got stuff
going on
i do i do jack murphy live on twitter
and if you're interested in the values
i'm talking about masculinity
brotherhood sovereignty and you're
looking for a community of people
like-minded values
check out the liminal order liminal
hyphen order dot com
also please give me a follow on youtube
new videos every day jack murphy live on
youtube thanks a lot
well thank you whities uh appreciate you
guys letting
me actually have a voice here but uh the
shirt that i'm wearing right now says
all my favorite channels have been
demonetized or
deleted there's been a lot of
demonetizations today especially with
channels like ford fisher
i know that hurts it happened to me
before so definitely go check out ford
but if you want to buy the per
the shirt you can on the
bestpoliticalshirts.com but one of the
best
smartest things you could do is sign up
on my email list and therefore there is
no big technocratic middle person saying
who i could talk to and who i can't
one-on-one communication on we are
change.org in the top
right hand corner put in your email it's
very easy
and i could talk to you which is very
important for me and my independent
media organization and
i hear someone is a single pringle oh
that would that would be me
join ian's only fans guys that's all
coming soon
we'll teach you how to make love to the
moon let's go slow
tantra is real you let the woman do most
of the moving uh we can get into that in
the in the
in the con in the uh paywall columns
that's your only fans yeah yeah we'll go
there and only fans um
jack thank you for coming i love you
you're such a force of positivity
and understanding negativity and using
it and manipulating your negative
jiu-jitsu
liminal order is awesome i know you guys
are blowing up and i want to just really
shout out the limo order that's such a
cool
opportunity to be around you while
you're building that thank you very much
yeah man it's mutual and you guys can
follow me at ian crossland on the
internet
i'm building up my twitch channel right
now i'm going twitch partner
the road to prosperity
and i am sour patch lids i am
at sour patch lids on twitter and mines
and then real sour patches on instagram
and gab i remember this time good for me
the next segment will be at timcast.com
thank you all so much for hanging out
and we will see you all there bye guys
you